[Music]
welcome one and all to the h3 podcast
experience or change it to experience oh
nice it feels more if we're trying to
compete with Joe Rogan's yeah why did
that start I don't know I tried to hype
it podcasts are boring it needs to be an
experience of the life changing
experience when you listen to this
podcast you will come out a different
person my guaranteed if you will lose
200 pounds just by listening that laughs
that way case study here this episode is
sponsored by ring stitch fix the black
tux and seat geek guys we are here with
the great and wonderful buggy we have a
lot to talk about
one of the main issues is is weight loss
and dealing with that and I thought
maybe some of you guys have some
interesting stories you'd like to share
with us today alive so give us a ring at
eight one eight two one four eight five
zero four if you would like to share
your story with us another note before
we get into it loving the end the intern
songs you guys put together last week
they're so freaking awesome
we had a competent not a competition but
people were making meme songs about her
intern awesome you bought blessed us
quickly Dan okay give me one sec anyway
send them to podcast at eight straight
reproductions calm and I'm going to tell
you guys what I'll tell you guys what
the favorite tunes are gonna want a
brand new flippin Samsung Galaxy S nine
plus eight enter it could be yours
today's guest needs no introduction the
great boogie2988 is back here with us
say last time you were here almost
exactly a year ago we had an amazing and
you have since then basically when you
were here previously you were just about
to undergo gastric bypass I was it was
June last year and then I got surgery
the second week of August
and now I'm down a hundred eighty pounds
180 pounds where did you start before
you wanted to circus ever five four well
because there was six hundred pounds but
just before surgery he Laurie started
the liquid diet was 540 yeah well yeah
and our doubts like three I guess I'm
not doing my math exactly I don't know
if it's a hundred eighty about down to
three sixty five sixty three sixty Wow
I got on the plane but I'm still
monumentally fat like I am tremendously
huge right I'm way more than both guys
who live in towns is right that's how
much that way so I've still got a long
ways to go I my doctor wants me to lose
another seventy five and then just get
right under 300 and then we got a lot of
skin to remove which we I like it's so
bad like I look like naked I look like
the Michelin Man blew a tire I look like
the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man
after the Ghostbusters movie I look like
the Elephant Man but only from the neck
down because it's so bad so at what
point during the weight loss do you say
okay I'm gonna remove the skin like
because yeah I know you want to lose
more right so they don't like to do it
within the first couple years they want
the skin to like shrink as much as it
can like tighten up and like they want
to make sure you got as much fat out of
there as you can right because it makes
it easier like cauterize and stuff and
at first I told them I don't want to do
that I'm not interested like this who
cares about this right right you know
okay it looks like I have a flying
squirrel I don't have a shed but there's
the chest and like this underbelly the
actual Fupa Fupa king I am still
undisputed it's like so uncomfortable
and it makes a difficult exercise and
makes it really so the skin gets in the
way yeah it's like straight up in the
way and so it does it's not gonna be
like that for everybody some people my
size or smaller don't have that problem
some people my size who are younger
don't have that problem but since I was
in my 40s and yes it's a real issue I
like the the nurse she's like so we'll
schedule that for the consultation or
the one-year mark and I'm like for the
plastic surgeon I'm not gonna get that
[ __ ] you know you trust me you're gonna
want it and then at the four month mark
I was like oh I really want that well
bad god bless I mean good problem to
have
yeah it's a good problem to have yeah I
I don't know it's just it's weird like
they talked about body dysmorphia and
you hear that term a lot would like for
people who're trans and stuff and I
didn't I was like
that's not a thing that I could
experience but like I was really looking
at old photos I took all my old photos
down I couldn't stand to look at him
right YouTube recommends one of my older
videos I'm like who is that guy I don't
even look like so what is the body
dysmorphia part because isn't that when
you like see yourself in a way that
you're not right so I still see myself
with like five hundred six and five okay
you don't see yourself any different
then I used I'll look at a street corner
and I'll think I can't walk to that but
I know I can now we're all like I'll be
putting on one of my shirts I'm down to
a 4x now this is like a six this has
fallen off me but I'll put on a 4x shirt
and I'm sliding it on I'm like oh this
is not going to over my body but it does
or like I'm walking through a restaurant
or a store and I'm like I can't fit down
that I it's just a actual disconnect
right with reality and like is that
affecting your yeah your continued
weight loss efforts
well they've not has been as great as I
would like nice I stalled right about I
stalled right about the control board
you yeah so you can sit back I sold
right about like 375 for a while and
then I started doing some pretty big
cuts to get down to like about a pound a
loss oh wait so I don't know like I your
listeners may not know right after I got
this surgery made my ex wife divorced
hmm and like you guys didn't know about
it until December but we had talked
about it for the first time in July and
then we made the agreement like we'll
get the surgery done and see what it's
like after the surgery but she was ready
to go and I was still like bleeding
really I was not even remotely recovered
I wasn't able to stand up I wasn't even
really cook for myself so they were
clean it was it was it was youthful I
mean it omma it's probably hard not to
be upset and to feel like a bandit in a
way because it seems like you were
vulnerable and and that's what I like
the timing sucked but yeah right I mean
what you were saying you went through a
divorce like life-changing weight loss
of a really intense surgery all within
the scope of three months by god I get
this like Fight Club mentality about it
like just like let's just burn it down
yeah and just start over like let's just
completely rebuild who and what I mean
you have nothing to lose exact just
[ __ ] right and so I told a therapist
actually lost my therapist over this
conversation but I'm a your pistol can
leave right here they're like I don't
want to work with you anymore because I
got the wrong idea in your head and I
think it was the right idea but she
disagreed entirely but I'm like so I
know that I made that happen that
doesn't seem very professional they're
like you know what you're too [ __ ] up
that's
I'm not a good fetes what they say it's
like it's not you it's not that's what
they gave me but I'm like buddy that
feel getting dropped by the shrink it
sucked but I just moved on to the next
one because it happens like sometimes
you're a good fit sometimes you're not
it's like anything else in there and if
you don't have a good therapist you're
not a good fit with that person that's
really hard we were really good fit for
real on top of the conversation I had
with her I'm like so I realized right
now I have to be miserable I've gone
through a divorce and divorces are
miserable you can write and I can't I'm
physically in pain all the time and I
can't rely on my one favorite thing in
the world which is food mm-hmm so I
can't drink I can't smoke I can't do it
I can't like shoot cocaine I can't do
anything mm-hmm I have no recourse so
I'm just gonna have to push through the
physical pain I'm gonna have to push
through the emotional pain I'll have to
I'm not gonna try to go back to an
addicts State of Mind and just try to
avoid it and try to deal with it and
like go back in a stupid bad habits cuz
I'm gonna get addicted to painkillers
I'm gonna get addicted to food again I'm
gonna poison myself you know um and I'm
like I just have to accept that I have
to be miserable for a while to do the
works like I mean not miserable in the
future right and she's like there's a
very destructive attitude you can't
think that way a sense to me right and
it was like what was what was it's like
if you choose to be miserable right now
you're gonna end up going back to old
habits what you need to do is you need
to start finding the joy in your daily
life and like under there isn't any
right there isn't to me this is just the
worst six months of my life and I just
have to deal with it yeah and I'm so
glad because now I'm out the six months
and I've went through the physical
therapy and I went through the divorce
and you know I've dated a little bit and
yeah yeah that was weird
how'd you meet him tinder believe it or
not yeah it's real so wait after how
long of being together so me me my
ex-wife were together for four seven
years Oh married for four and so that
was tough and so like every girl that
I've met on tinder I did the opposite of
like try to woo them I was like so
here's the thing I just went through a
divorce and I also got gastric bypass
surgery I I look like I'm melting
physically my problem my brain is on
fire but I'm not looking to get into a
relationship or nor do I ever want to be
one and again I plan to die alone
would you like me can we no Marvel movie
with me because that's all I want a just
want somebody goes to the Marvel movie
with you you like Marvel movies let's go
see Marvin yeah I can go with my friends
that's fine so you said no not a fad
right it's not and so like a the biggest
thing is is you know I'm not a
good-looking guy you know I have like
all seven teeth so like the girls are
not physically like excited but like
they know me from YouTube that's what's
been been a big part of it they're like
well I know you you helped my cousin you
helped my my brother you helped me so
you've gone on her ample dates to the
movies yeah and as anything is there new
special there was one girl who seems
like two and a half months and that was
fun and she was really nice but just
wasn't a great fit like she wanted more
that I could like provide because I
understand like emotionally there yeah I
was too busy like done with XY stuff and
all that stuff so that was kind of nice
but yeah it's just I don't know a it I
don't know it I don't know if I'll ever
like trust again like that's a stupid
thing to say but it's hard
ya know but like at the same time like I
have I'm not really angry my ex-wife and
I don't really feel like I should be
because we weren't happy right sure you
know and like that VidCon I've never
said this elsewhere and this is the only
place I would ever say this that last
VidCon not just because the Anita
sarkeesian your was that when you were
here yes like we meet get me my ex-wife
were at our worst during that VidCon
traveling was so bad we were having like
an unhappy time in the hotel and an
unhappy time in the car owner what here
it was a brick wall let me I want to say
I want to say something yeah you were
here almost a year ago you're here with
your ex-wife yeah and when you came here
it was a such a struggle for you to
physically walk in here you were taking
breaks yeah you could you came you sat
here because you couldn't really write
like we talked about
we took the little intermission you guys
got up and walked around and I literally
sit here and look at my phone you know I
had to piss because I couldn't write but
I'll say this
yeah can you pull those pictures up this
time you walked in on by yourself you're
slamming around you stood up and took a
photo here as well like this was the one
before you couldn't get up so we went
over to that side and took the photo so
hard look here's the news so hard
looking at these older pictures for me I
really
but it does it not here blow that up a
little bit and this one [ __ ] we did
it in that goddamn iconic spot yeah and
that's look you look great man that's a
that's a really good photo I'm getting
there
you know like I don't know most people
in they lose weight they look younger
and I'm getting older because you know
like fat doesn't crack is the joke right
and so like I started to see the crows I
don't agree by the way why do you what
do you what do you feel sad when you
look at the old photo of you because I
to me I know the state I was in mentally
and I was just like defeated and I
didn't care to fight like the morbid
obesity and I was trying like to get my
brain around it and to want to do it and
want to be healthy and want to be better
but I just didn't give a [ __ ] on some
level and that's why I just couldn't
push myself thing every licked right and
like the surgery I mean that was what is
like physical rehab like being forced
rehab surgical rehab what was there a
moment or kind of a catalyst where
you're like you know what I need to like
you finally something click because you
on your by your own will lost what 60 80
pounds before you could even get this
right and and that was like I think I
think the testament is you have to
you're supposed to do a two-week
entirely liquid diet like 800 calories a
day for the first two weeks to prepare
your liver and drink calories right holy
crap you got to prepare your liver you
got to prepare your body for the surgery
and if you cheat on that diet and they
open you up and see that you didn't do
it then they will not do the surgery
whoa right that's serious
they just like alright you got him up
right patch him up we can't do it Wow
so going into that knowing that I'm like
you know how am I gonna do this I've
never been able to put down a fork in my
life how am I gonna do this and then I
just did it and what was it what was it
that I was dying like I was history you
felt it like mush I was like 240 over
210 sometimes like with the anxiety and
like the the physical stress I was in I
was taking wads and medication to keep
my blood pressure down and I was just
straight dying and my surgeon is like
ideally you would get all the way down
to 425 before we do anything mm and you
know doing it as such a larger size
means you're you're bottoming out will
be way higher than we want it to be you
know if we look at the bell curve and
you'll uh get into calculators less
you're gonna get down to 300 and that's
where you're gonna stop boogie and
that's just the math of it it'll take
incredible discipline for the rest of
your life to get done right and but if
we do it at 400 we'll get you down at
225 right
and I'm like [ __ ] okay but he's like we
have to do it now because you are dime
yeah so let's pull the trigger I want to
save your life because I know you'll pay
it forward so now it's been a little bit
of a time you've lost like 180 pounds
you said like physically how do you feel
like I mean it's been a since all this
stuff [ __ ] tag yeah it's got to feel
like you [ __ ] walked up here yeah
yourself I haven't felt this good since
I was 20 well and like I flew in 83 last
week and you know Jeff Healey the
YouTube team they put me on camera for
like five or six segments and I get to
host my own segment interview developers
is amazing
great opportunity couldn't have done
that otherwise but normally when I flew
into LA every time I've ever had to fly
in LA I needed fiscal assistance so if a
fan saw me they saw me in a [ __ ]
wheelchair get pushed by somebody last
VidCon you're in a wheelchair right robe
for part of it and I still my doctor
still wants me running the motor scooter
for these events but I just Park it and
I don't bring it anywhere and I don't do
anything but I have it it's like you
wanted in case he pulls back muscle at
AC you do Hayes case you go too far but
like I went to a fortnight event during
e3 and abandon the cart you know ten
miles back at the hotel and I was on my
feet for like two and a half hours and
much like marshmallow and that's amazing
and logic right I like a logic and
concert and like yeah I don't know it's
just like I can do that now and I want
to do it so I hate having to keep that
thing but I do use it a little bit at
these events just to be safe but are you
afraid like it's funny I was tough our
previous guest Tom Segura I was talking
to him about weight loss by every stand
a much different scale but he said
something I thought was what's funny but
very true he's like he used to be really
big and lost a ton of weight yeah I said
I always feel like I'm five days away
from completely relapsing I could see
that it was how do you feel about well
after the surgery do you feel like
you're super motivated to keep going or
you still feel like super motivated
right now but I talked to a lot of
people in a way I talked a lot of people
on on the subreddit I talked to a lot of
people on the Facebook groups you know
these these Recovery Group C surgery
groups and like I'm in several and
there's some people like one guy in my
area I don't want to doc some
um but he you know never allowed to
smoke again
because if you do you can perforate the
surgical scars in your stomach well and
so the smoker right he started smoking
again at the six-month mark and now it's
been a one year since the surgery and he
has perforated his stomach and so what
does that mean basically there's holes
in the surgical lining of his stomach
and so he's literally he eats when he
eats he's dumping stomach juices and
food so it's almost worse off right so
like the chances of him buying any day
is like happening and I'm like I'm
learning from him like how do you how do
you know why are you doing that I guess
I don't know it's a stress ring right
and you're you're under more stress than
you've ever been
yeah and and like you said I mean food
is is kind of always been something that
you've leaned on then the good news is
our cigarettes in his case the good news
is I will tell your audience that I've
told them before there were a couple of
times like right after the divorce I was
like you know what
um cake is delicious so I don't give a
[ __ ]
I'm ready cake mm-hmm and it made me
very very sick and maybe very very ill
because your summit but I'm so sick all
alive it's because like I just wasn't
used to those foods anymore I'm over it
right and so I like I'll push through it
because I'm really really dedicated to
looking this up I guess and so you're
saying you felt off on but you kept
eating right you know what man I'm gonna
eat this I'm gonna go back in a
self-destructive mode and do it and then
my stomach the surgery kicks in and it's
like hey boss you know we can only eat
about for us as a food still right and
like oh so that's why the surgery is so
useful because in that moment a weakness
not only do I feel bad not only do I
feel sick not only do I not enjoy what
I've done but then like I physically
can't do it to a point that'll damage me
and there's this misconception that you
your stomach stretches over time if you
abuse it and stuff and they've done
autopsies some people have years ago
it's just not true so how is it that you
have a ceiling right because they say oh
yeah the food what I mean it depends on
what you're eating right like 8 ounces
of cake is gonna be too 3,000 calories
right but 8 ounces of lean chicken
there's gonna be four or 500 colors what
I mean is like over eight months you say
that's your opportunity to lose weight
is that because your stomach regrows
so okay so the way they explained it
most people will lose weight for the
first year and a half and at the end of
that year and a half all of the fun
parts of the surgery are gone
one man being like you're gonna start
feeling hunger again about the six-month
mark all of that all that all the
assistance basically right and that's
gonna come down to discipline and then
the other thing is your body does not
like what you're doing to it when you
lose weight that quickly so you do get
some metabolic hits and your body is
resistant for the rest of your life to
process fat to process calories you know
it's still gonna a bay the laws of
thermodynamics you know so it will then
try to choose to burn protein it's going
to try to burn your muscle and warmer
your fat for example bad and so you got
a struggle with little things like that
your body learns hey we once start for a
year and a half and I don't ever want
that to happen again
so let's make sure it doesn't and they
tell you and this is not a hard and fast
rule because you can't change the math
but they say like if you figure out your
basal metabolic rate at 2500 calories
you should deduct 6 to 800 calories from
that and to get your actual BMR so a
normal person normal person your size
probably about 2,500 hours a day mmm
what if I'm your size then I should
probably be eating closer to 19 just to
maintain just to maintain wow that's
pretty
and so basically rough yeah you got it
right for the rest of your life and it's
tough yeah but if you lose that
motivation I really think you you you're
five days away from whatever was a total
landslide I'm so tremendously motivated
because I'm doing stuff I've never got
to do and it's just part of my life I
would rent about for 20 years you know
it's on disability building a YouTube
channel a man one of these days I'm
gonna be able to go to e3 one of these
days and remember to go beyond my
favorite podcast my favorite shows meet
my favorite creators meet my fans and
and then I couldn't I got to the point
where I had the power I had the money
but I couldn't physically do it right
and now I can do both and now like I
feel like I'm struggling on YouTube go
check me out youtube.com slash crooked
you 90-day I feel like I'm struggling
there because my audience is kind of
split because I always did the gaming
stuff but my gaming audience got flooded
with all these very personal videos
during the divorce and the surgery so I
have like a very personal audience right
now that doesn't care to watch the
gaming stuff
um and but the gamers are frustrated
because there's too much personal stuff
and have that like weird split audience
issue and then nothing performs well on
the out rhythm I'm just gonna have to
pick a direction to go with it I don't
think so but let's talk about that yeah
after the break I'm curious to pick your
brain on that a little bit cuz I have
thoughts about that too cuz I've been
that position so many times right but
let's talk about that after break we
will be right back
absolutely thank you to ring for
sponsoring this episode now Dan can you
play the angelic music please because
this is serious this is a product that
has revolutionized the earth thank you
Dan this is a product so great usually
sponsors they approached us I said no I
sought out ring and I said I love you so
much give me the opportunity know the
privilege they're like alright get on
with the read let me tell you about this
ring it's an electronic doorbell that
has a camera it has a speaker a live
feed and it saves the video and a motion
detector all in a frickin doorbell are
you kidding me it used to cost thousands
of dollars you'd have to contract people
to come install all this crazy equipment
in your house to get security now all
you need is this one incredible device
the ring they call it the ring because
it's like a halo that goes around an
angel that's who invented this God an
angel this product changed my life
at a previous house we didn't have a
people so install this ring all of a
sudden uh-oh
I can talk to people when I'm not even
at home I can see all these nerds at my
door that I don't want to talk to I can
put on the speaker and be like piss off
or leave the package leave it and leave
and you leave
hmm it doesn't matter if you own a house
if you're in apartment even if you're in
a dorm that's the beauty of it you can
tie it to your doorbell so it has power
piped in but you can also battery power
it if you're in a dorm room or something
like that boom I've got a ring
nobody's gonna surprise me and by the
way this is the best thing
motion detector Oh somebody walks by it
saves it so you get to watch a ladybug
what's oh the girl who had a crush on
was at the front of my door inch but she
didn't have the courage to knock
now that's saved and you know ring saved
your marriage because you didn't know
she was into it but now you do I cannot
endorse this product enough they have a
special offer available for our
listeners right now the ring starter
kits with a video doorbell motion
activated floodlight camera and starter
kit has everything you need to build a
ring of security around your home it's
about safety people it's about seeing
what's out there
it's about finding real love it's about
love all right now that's it so please
guys check this out go to ring.com slash
h3 that's ring.com slash h3 I guarantee
this product it's gonna change
everything you knew about the world
style some of us have it and some of us
don't that's right and let's face it a
lot of us guys it's hard to wait it's
hard enough to wake up in the morning or
girls or ladies it's hard enough to wake
up in the morning let alone oh you got
to get up and dress yourself are you
freaking kidding me if you're like me
you just leave a pile of dirty clothing
on them on the floor before I met ela I
literally would just leave a pile of
used clothes and put that back on
because who's got time I saw that when
you're so critically depressed that you
can't even get out of bed well I can't
help with your depression but I can't
help with the clothing stitch fix all
right six fix has reinvented how we buy
clothing you just go to the website
answer some basic questions about your
sizes favorite styles budget and write
from your laptop smartphone or tablet
boom you're slamming your personal
stylist and springs into action they're
snoozing and then there they wake what's
that name I sleep I'm awake that's them
and selecting five brand new clothing
items just for you I know I know
they make me say I know I know I know I
know
personal stylist sounds like something
only the rich and famous can afford but
you can to your sloppy [ __ ]
try not say [ __ ] your sloppy dip stitch
fix styling is their styling fee is only
20 bucks which is applied as a credit
towards anything you keep that's pretty
sweet so it's pretty much none no don't
charge you anything and since your
personal stylist uses only your
preference to pick your clothing
you're still in complete control of what
you get once your items arrive you try
them on and you only pay for what you
keep if you don't like something if you
need another size just send it back no
questions asked they may they won't even
smell it they say no questions ask them
no smells and shipping is always free
both ways get your fix whenever you want
or sign up to receive scheduled
shipments the choice is yours
I love stitch fits dan dan loves stitch
fix he's using it all the freaking time
and I can verify it that he's had some
hot dates that have gone very well
specifically because he's looked so good
how can you verify that because he's
told me oh right then you know what
buddy
hurry desist fix calm slash h3 to get
started now keep all five items in your
box and you'll get 25% off your entire
purchase that's stitch fix calm slash h3
stitch fix calm slash h3 welcome back to
the h3 podcast experience feels good
right it does I'm I can feel my life
changing so we were just talking about
how you're split on YouTube content cuz
you have the the like emotional or
personal I guess like better and you
have gaming content and I like perform
so much better right performs better I
have a video can right now that took me
10 years to make but like I talked to
you a little bit about last year I
talked about like the abuse that I went
through as a kid but I never like really
when to these details so just I got home
from e3 and I turn on the camera and I'm
like tonight's tonight just yet it's
been dead 10 years I'm gonna make the
video who's been dead
mom like all this terrible [ __ ] and you
know what I'm just gonna put it out
there and I filmed it and I'm gonna
either set of life today or tomorrow
it's not live yet no yeah it should go
gangbusters I hope I think audience will
respond to it and it's gonna feel
amazing to get that [ __ ] out so the
emotional stuff does better than the
video game stuff right and then like the
gaming stuff kind of does okay and
surprisingly when I do the Francis
character I bleed subscribers now and I
think part of it's because he's not as
funny because I'm not as fat and I think
that's a part of it I think a part of it
is they've learned to know me and they
don't like that side yeah you don't need
it I don't need it right and but the
problem is I still find myself and I
think you I think this is exactly what
your guys are gonna like I think it's
we're ever crater has to land mmm you
create what you want to create what you
were passionate about what you you have
to yeah the most important I think that
you're I know in your head like when you
see that the views are lower on one
video and higher it gets really
stressful right because you want to see
every video doing great right but the
truth is and I've learned this the poor
performance of one video doesn't or like
people are willing to stick around and
get the videos they want right you can
have both it's totally fine right and I
have like and so that's a lot they get
YouTube in your ear and their life you
consistency consistency great I know
people at YouTube don't even make
youtube videos right they don't know
anything about what it means to be a
youtuber right and no fault like my rap
or anybody like that yeah I know you
guys right but at the end of the day
like I I was so blessed to have like a
core audience of like a hundred thousand
people who would watch me eat a bucket
exactly right and exaggerate probably
get more for that and here's the thing
is you know you about 8 ounces of [ __ ]
yeah not even a bucket it the thing is
if you get in your head you're like oh I
just need to make emotional it is how
[ __ ] up is that
right exactly all the sudden you're like
what what like then maybe you're not
emotional in it today I'm having a good
day and I'll do what kind of right it
sucked up and and and you're gonna get
stuck in a box where you're all the
sudden getting stressed out because you
don't know how to make other content
than that an hour create there are
content creators I watched one yesterday
he tweeted me something and he averages
well I'm just going to say this wheezy
waiter if you remember him from YouTube
royalty days
and he still makes videos at 15:20 kpop
and I I said that I scratch my head I'm
like man why you know but cuz he loves
doing it cuz he's passionate about cuz
he liked what he does and he has an
audience of 15,000 people one Harrison
Wright I went saw Bo Burnham he's on the
show in a couple weeks
yeah I love that my super excited um but
I wouldn't watch Bo Burnham in the house
of 1,400 people right and that's a big
audience for boat but was excited 14
where people came out wide to watch me
that's a huge so if you've got a twenty
thousand people watching everything you
do congratulations Weezy yeah it's
awesome by the way there's never any
rule people think that like on YouTube
when you channel winds down that you can
never come back it's like oh you're
stuck like I've actually seen several
times I mean you could even say it about
Philip DeFranco Oh different girls are
perfect like his channel was getting it
was really slowing down he was down to
boogie level of views for a while I
don't know what his views were at I was
like a couple hundred thousand now I
don't know I actually don't really know
what happened specifically but whatever
he changed I think his his show got more
professional like the celebrity gossip
[ __ ] which is okay so and no more like
girl of the day which was like like it's
not for this political climate you know
so he fixed the show and now he's up
over a million every freaking I think
Jack's seen that a lot of I think jacket
Jax homes is another perfect example
where like your grammar sucks was like
killer and he's just killing it and like
to 35 million own upload and then like
he was experimenting and figuring stuff
out and he's down to like boogie level
of numbers for a while like diva two or
three hundred thousand less he and then
guy hits and then boom now it's two he's
got five million again yeah
questionnaires we figured out what works
and even Felix to an extent because he
never really dipped like below like two
million per video yeah but it's like you
gotta take your time it's perfect on
YouTube people like panic when they see
the numbers going down right and it's
hard not to it's [ __ ] feels all right
it's like right there in the works
exactly the number it is no like I
wonder what this one got like on Netflix
do you have no idea what one that'd be
right yeah they still don't they still
impose YouTube read original numbers
like nobody has like know if those ever
got
watched by anyone ever yeah here's a
hint most of them have not well yeah the
numbers probably look really really
small compared to free videos yeah right
exactly but the thing that being a
youtuber so toxic and it's so it's so
hard like emotionally but the thing is
like it happens to everybody who's been
on the platform for a long time you
definitely you have been Flo yep and you
got to like rediscover your voice I
learned to just let it go
and just like because I knew going into
the surgery I was like a lot of people
are in my ear
a lot of fans on Twitter like when you
lose weight people are gonna watch and
like you know what if that happens it's
okay because I'm turning my life around
and like my ex-wife we're talking about
divorcing why what's the theory that
people wouldn't watch because the only
thing I'm interesting only thing
interesting about me is that a vet how
is that interesting I don't know I don't
know or that some of my audience who's
also big would see me succeed and that
would make them frustrated or irritated
or resilient saying or something like
that like I'm like those statements
doesn't mean anything it's all like
theory crafting people love the theory
craft and you know but yeah I'm just
like there's a gaming term from back all
the day like your deck building decks or
a building Dede characters you like you
just like a well let's see how this will
work seriously we're all three or three
crafting here I want to ask you
something I saw this statistic and it
absolutely blew my mind yeah and tell me
how kind of how it resonates with you if
an over if an obese person starts their
marriage when they're obese when they
start losing weight or like get guys
gastric bypass right the chance of
divorce after surgery is eighty to
eighty-five percent yeah oh I was
completely flabbergasted by that man
they go over that number
my my my pre education for the the
surgery is so comprehensive they
included that statistic one point what
do you make like what do you make of
that that it's almost like it's almost
certain well let me ask you this before
you did the surgery did you think oh
were you like oh that's that's not us um
I had a pretty good feeling come that
July when we had that talk yeah like
she's definitely maybe looking towards
the door right now she's definitely
looking towards not enjoying her life
right now and I don't blame her she was
in a caretaker role man so you mean like
resonate
with you yeah and I'm like man I think
that might happen but I asked her one
day I'm like what do you think about
that it she's like look that's not us
we're gonna be fine and and I think part
of that even though I think she maybe
already had an eye on the door that was
her saying look I have to tell him that
because I want to make sure I save his
life here I'm not gonna leave him in
ruins mm-hmm you know I'm not gonna
leave him to die alone and so I you know
but maybe that's how she really was
thinking who knows but what she likes to
talk to ever talk to people who have
gone through the surgery and seen
marriages end there's like three major
school of thoughts okay so it could have
been that I got the surgery and was
unsatisfied with my partner and decided
to upgrade that happens then there are
people who marry somebody who's morbidly
obese and think they're always gonna be
like that they're always gonna be there
for me they always make me feel better
about myself maybe something like that
and then that person starts to turn
their life around and they're like well
the dynamic changes right and I think
that might even close to what happened
for me and my ex-wife in some ways we
were always we already had our trouble
but I think we're in a situation where I
was getting my stuff together and she's
like what is my role in this codependent
relationship no like it's gonna be a
bleakly change and if it's going to
completely change now as an opportunity
for me to build into something
completely different
mmm I think that's probably where her
headspace was more than anything like
now if I'm gonna rebuild myself anyway
let's see if I can do make myself
happier as I think really what it was
but I think that's I think you have
people who who get through the surgery
and like I'm a better person I deserve a
better partner and you got people who
who were married to somebody who are
they're in a caretaker role and
everything so when you say caretaker
role as it's almost as if that appeals
to the the part of the spouse I think
like they come in and they like being
that right there ought to be the
character they one day that I once dated
a girl who was a feeder if you're
familiar that tell me about that I'm not
very so I met her on like ice cream back
in 2005 or something - how much did you
weigh at the time I was about 550 oh I
was 512 was like she's a girl who got me
up to 600 okay so if she completely
enabled you yeah she's like straight up
right she's like I want you to be so big
like we moved in and we had this
conversation actually I want you to be
so big one day that you can't get out of
bed I want you so big one day that
you're one of the biggest men on record
what the [ __ ] you sexual turn-on for
NASA's said tool very sir let me ask you
if I can get does she
how does she get sexual gratification of
that um I guess just the body type like
she liked the softness of it does she
like my like yeah like stir like the the
feeding aspect is foreplay like dinner
is foreplay that's and what's and what's
the honk Grand Slam is just sex you know
like I guess I guess ideally I've talked
to people who got so large that they
weren't able to have sex and certainly a
lot of positions are compromised when I
was five fifty six hundred but you can
still say man do yeah we and but
eventually I guess you had fed me to a
point where I wasn't physically able to
do that anymore and that I don't know
what it would have been and did you know
about to some extent but she's pretty
she was pretty upright she's tiny she's
like 110 pounds oh that is the string
one of the best girls ever dated how did
that make you feel I mean like being in
that relationship knowing what it well I
was like suicidal and like
self-destructive anyway so I was like
hey I get to some hires and also get
laid a lot this is awesome and she was
pushing me to do stuff I had never done
before like she's getting me back into
the gym to trying to stay fit but also
still fat huh you know she wanted
otherwise right and otherwise you're
gonna get so that you know you want to
be able to eat anymore I want you to be
to always be able to knock it out right
huh how would you be able to just burn
those calories was she trying to kill
you yeah that's she wanted that's the
deal that's a deal with centimeters yeah
not all well I mean where's the words
the road and yes some for someone is
just like a control thing mmm oh yeah I
want to control you and some of them
it's like the only feature that would
she feed you while you guys were having
sex yeah I ever I have a real sexy story
that I would never talk about I'm just
I'm intrigued by the whole thing
so we decide to do Thanksgiving dinner
together right and she I stayed the
night at her place
and she wakes up that morning at like
5:00 a.m. to start cooking that Couric
turkey she base it like it's her [ __ ]
career dude and and so I'm so fat I
can't fit into her pantry but she's got
some bags in the pantry and like we
Thanksgiving dinner and I down like a
two liter of
vanilla coke and I'm like ate half that
turkey and half all the sides and I'd
like a pie for breakfast to start the
day and then she's like hey it's time
for dessert and I'm like I can't eat
another bite she goes were you better
and like what is for a dessert I ate the
only pie in the house for [ __ ]
breakfast okay like what do you want
from me this is one I hate the story now
looking back on because I feel like such
a terrible glutton I can't believe this
is where my head was is I would never
think this way anymore but I was like so
into it she goes into the pantry and
grab this like bag and she goes into the
bedroom and closes the door and I'm like
doing this like trying to get food to
settle so I try to make room I try to
burp and stuff cuz I know I'm gonna have
to eat I was gonna be real food so she
oh she's like come in and I'm so sorry
this is sculling story she's uh she's
taken Oreo cookies and she's laid them
across her chest down her stomach to
make an arrow to her vagina and then she
had filled her vagina maraschino
cherries I swear to God and my thought
is you are going to get a yeast
infection what the [ __ ] are you doing
like don't put food in your vagina how
many of you stuff it was like you know
well it was like one of the best
experiences of my life I was like this
is awesome you ate them all out yeah you
do what you got to do and then you know
you went to Tel you ate them all out yes
quite literally and together for a while
and then I got sick I got like an
infection to my leg which is like real
frequent I get in with the lymphedema
all the time and I'm like I gotta go to
the hospital she's like they're gonna
make you lose weight and I'm like no no
no that's gonna be fine I go to the
argon for force because if you go to the
hospital we're done and like mom what
what [ __ ] you okay we're done like I'm
not gonna die like a learner she's like
you're faking the infection like how do
you fake an infection
what do you walk into this [ __ ] was
toys ahead yeah
I mean she was fine I mean she might be
very well listening to this if you are
high and she was fine you know but that
stuff was pretty messed up you know now
is the only deal-breaker she's a
perfectly great person well
trendafil yeah right yeah but other than
that she's a great murderer out of my
favorite burgers I mean it is as far as
murder goes yeah that's a good way to go
yeah you know so what happened how did
the relationship end I ended up I end up
going to the hospital that night and she
wouldn't stayed in hotel Wow and then
like we like talked it out or whatever
I'm like look if you move back in this
is my body is my choice I decided what
to do and she's like oh I can't believe
how you've changed and like yeah but I
don't know this is like the slightest
molecule of self esteem that I found
everyone hold on to it so you can either
be with me like that or not you know and
I'm not saying I'll lose weight I'm not
saying I won't get ten times fatter I'm
saying if I do it's my choice and then
like that Friday she's like off work and
she's like I'm coming home tonight and
I'm like
and she's like let's go out to dinner
I'm like great there's this Chinese
place I've always wanted to take you
because no no we need to go to a buffet
were you you tubing at this time no this
is 2005-2006 so she's like you need to
go to a buffet I'm like I don't want to
go to a buffet I want to take you to
this Chinese place oh you do real-life
stuff I think no we had to go to a fair
we're done I'm like okay when you get
here your [ __ ] will be on the lawn once
you got there it was on the line I
called a couple friends over there uh
well good for you
I would she was gonna line my and like
you know like he that's my version of
the story I'm sure she has a fleet of
reversion she probably thinks up a crazy
piece of [ __ ] so it's hard to come it's
hard to I don't know I don't know I've
never told the story I don't know if she
has a defensible position yeah I don't
know man women are tough and then like
if you look the way I look and you had
the life that I had you're not gonna
meet a awesome young lady like this one
you you know you're gonna probably meet
some crazies every once in a while I've
met some really great everyone it's
crazy that's every once in a while but I
see what you mean that there's women who
are attracted to people in your
condition right yeah that wouldn't I
wouldn't necessarily ever interact with
with someone like that
yeah and and yeah right and then again I
think you know you gotta be careful
especially dating right now I'm
especially careful like if I have a girl
over the house I'm like so this is a
no-phone zone you know and here's a
burner a good call
here's a burner phone right here if you
and I'm gonna let you put in your pocket
and if you need to call 9-1-1
you need to call friend
right there on that phone your phone
stays in the car cuz I don't wanna be
filmed yeah I don't want anybody
recording the house and only the socks I
mean really carefully you know and to be
private and I want to make sure if I'm
texting you I'm very careful when I text
you want to do video chat I'm gonna make
sure whatever I do is very very you know
cuz I'm not gonna get what I yes
shaycarl really went through the the
works you know cuz he was talking to a
girl or whatever yeah but he I mean he
was feeling married and stuff and he was
like mister of happy family right right
and so like you know that but that girl
dumped like everything he said and into
the world and you just gotta like be
super careful you know that story yeah I
never actually IQ such as never met him
I was like it's one mistake in that
entire marriage to it's like the one
time he he's straight even the tiniest
bit which you shouldn't do every
straight quite a bit as I understand
well I think it was when it all just
Tekken easy stuff it was like just
talking to ass in here like nasty drunk
like [ __ ] nasty but like there's some
women and men out there who just like
paying other people every Friday night
and go home with her husband right you
know and it's like he was I think it was
the juxtaposition of mr. happy family
that really that's what it was right
right
like you find out somebody else was like
talking to a stripper after 20 years of
marriage you be like that's kind of
[ __ ] up but since it was shade mister
hey yeah happy family that story was
something man I gotta tell you I tell I
like I was a great that was something it
was weird man
I've got so many like messed up stories
I I just literally no end to them to be
doing story time videos till I'm dead
that is where that was that's one of my
favorites man I've ever that one night
on stream when I was like depersonalized
or whatever I'd like to see what I'm
curious and don't you don't have to
answer because it is it's gross and it's
personal I'm just wondering what
position reverse cowgirl is the only
thing that worked at the bicker so
reverse cowgirls her ass facing you yeah
damn yeah her pretty much stand on my
toes my horribly misshapen terrible
lymphedema of infested toes
know what she was into but she was into
it I mean if that's the only one you get
that's not a bad one and then like
Buddha was you know when I was with
someone that's smaller like 550 500 then
missionary works but that's pretty much
about it
mm-hmm and now I was with a girl I was
on top for the first time with a girl
recently we're still having to do like
the edge of bad stuff and I swear to god
she had to be like the open mind of this
girl in the world cuz I literally had to
like lift [ __ ] up and put it on her
you're into it so thank you so you had
sex recently since the divorce a couple
times couple nice it's been it's been
and it was missionary well it was we
were using we're utilizing the edge of
the bed Lupo okay and then I did manage
to do a little bit of doggy I managed to
walk you believe this re to my core
audience because you guys are not used
to this so sorry no this is okay so
we're really gonna into this girl is
like like straight up like it
Arkansas ten but like an LA eight
probably I mean oh so she does like
she's good-looking what she look like I
mean what's her what's her way she's
about 110 I think she's having like some
weight issues cuz like she she does like
camming and stuff for a living
oh [ __ ] and so she like you know they're
always wanted to be smaller than you
actually actually is great
you really he's like I guess it turned
out to be a rebound but like it was like
she was really healing she was really
like on board and she like knew my work
and like I'm helpful and obviously it
was it was a good experience that's
gotta be motivating it was right then
I'm like I saw her and then I like went
on a few first dates and this first date
start in the second dates and then I get
to the third date and then sometimes we
go back to my place until she would and
it'll be like I was not ready for any of
this I don't know like I don't want you
to see me naked look at me she was into
it like and that's the thing some girls
she was happy with some girls I'll say
that what she cried honestly don't care
now she was like this she's fine she's
uh yeah she's smart girl she's strong
powerful smart girl for her age then
they're shocked that just told is she
what's the Haiti she will be able to
legally drink soon yeah yeah it was bad
man it's not bad she's illegal you're
out there you're shaking your dick it
was you know but that's fine you know
look it was fine I don't know I can't
believe I'm talking about that might
I've never even talked about this might
stream do what you do to me you just get
this [ __ ] out of me man this is great
this is cathartic this is interesting
cuz you know well I I will tell you I
wasn't making decisions I do not
remember most of November any of
December most of January part of Faber
I like depersonalized I go back and
watch videos that I made during that
period of time I don't know what the
[ __ ] is looking to probably things I
write because I I just I I if I was ever
gonna like harm myself that's when I
would have done it if I was ever gonna
eat til my stomach popped or something
that's when I would have done it cuz I
was in zero control but I talk to my
friends and they're like oh you're just
like really sad for a while and like you
had us over every week and like we play
D&D and stuff and you pet the dog boogie
I love you that was great
that came out really weird what I'm
trying to do is cut to the second break
and I'm very uh neligan and better but I
love talking to you and I cannot wait
what's a return to return to our
conversation around I promise you no
more sex stories it's no more stories
well yeah okay there you go you guys
have the scouts honor
all right we'll see you guys soon after
these commercials break wedding season
is upon us and if you are a disgusting
monster like me then chances are you
probably don't even have a tux or a suit
and you don't want to roll up like me
and be the guy that's in a collared
shirt and jeans at a black-and-white
tuxedo wedding you do not want to be
that guy take it from me but it's true
based on true and recent events okay you
want to look like this guy and you want
everyone to be like damn this guy went
through the effort to look good and I'm
telling you people respect that
they're gonna respond to that and you
don't have to drop a trillion dollars
that's why Bach tux is great the black
tux you want to look fresh but it's also
convenient and that is what's so awesome
about shopping for tuxedos online rent
them online the black tux offers the
kind of suits and tuxedos styles who
would normally be wildly expensive to
buy and you're probably only going to
wear it once like the Emerald shod
tuxedo it's funky it's cool and how many
times you're gonna wear an emerald green
tuxedo I mean it looks great with the
black tux you can do you blow it out for
one big-time event and send it back you
don't have to own this thing forever
guys it's not like a wedding gown so try
out a new look do something different
and take your style to the next level
but the black tux free home try on you
can see the fit feel the quality of your
suit months before your event after
ordering your suit will arrive 14 days
before your event if anything is less
than perfect the black tux will send you
a replacement right away I remember how
simple it returns on you wear it yet
turned heads then you send it back three
days after your event and shipping is
free both ways
forget about it ah standout at your
event for the right reasons
that's exactly right I stood out for the
wrong reasons and trust me don't do that
so you're gonna get 20 bucks off your
purchase visit the black tux comm slash
h3h3 that's the black tux dot-com / h3h3
for $20 off your purchase double act tux
premium rental suits and tuxedos
fricking delivered to your god dang
flippin door or wherever you want it
SeatGeek boom love it if you need
tickets to an event a concert sporting
event whatever do it with seeking they
are by far my favorite if you need
tickets you go you see the seat you see
what kind of deal it is you go on there
you buy it tells you how good the seat
is how good the deal is and even beyond
that it shows you the view from the seat
you know everything in advance you know
the price it's incredible
check it out boom post some alone
tickets give it a shot he's on tour he's
the best
and what see kick it's so easy and fresh
here's a hook-up that you're not gonna
want to miss use code h3h3 for $20 off
your first order that's a ticket folks
that's a set price they're just hooking
you up 20 bucks to go see a show on them
seeking puts a 1 to 10 score on each
ticket to let you know if you're getting
a good deal or a bad one green means
good red means bad
simple as that every time I've used
Sikhi I've had a great time because I
knew exactly what I was getting myself
into and I was always never disappointed
it's the beauty of it
just click the me tab on the app and
enter code h3h3 for $20 off click the
link in the description to download the
app use code h3h3 for $20 off your first
seat geek order I got to tell you guys
you are not gonna regret it give them a
shot you're gonna have a great time and
you were gonna be using this app forever
when you go see shows concerts sporting
that's anything 20 bucks
off thank you so much appreciate you
guys let's get back into it
[Music]
welcome back to the experience now
here's what's burning yeah yeah this is
the experience I want the owner in here
with buggy let's take some calls awesome
yeah I just the people worried at home I
want you to know I have checked my phone
and I have no angry text from exo so
either they're not listening and lawyers
will call me later have some great
stories yes feel bad that was this this
is the real [ __ ] this was him and it was
very you're going through it's
interesting too it's it's interesting I
I you know like normally have not shared
it on my own space because I wanted to
be very kind to the people who have
shared their time with me and you want
to be yeah but I feel like mostly
stories I think they're ok they're
generic I don't think yeah they're gonna
be fine you'd never figure out who these
people are right no no no how many how
many 20 year old cam girls are there
three in the whole world today one one
follows me every day you get that spam
you know yeah maybe they're verified or
something you know and get a follow it's
a girl right
I think what happens is they hackers get
a hold of verified accounts wipe it all
put on a cam girl link and and be like
hey sweetheart come watch me live deep
that's gotta be one you know one of the
most controversial things that have
happened since the divorce got about a
month after the divorce I followed a
girl on Twitter mmm and like one of her
photos and it turns out that she was
like a cam girl I didn't really fully
realized just that message me I followed
her liked her photo and then that got
shared in the feed because that's right
when they introduced someone you follow
likes a thing it'll get shared in the
feed but the photo wasn't like nude or
anything she was just wearing like a
Jerrica right now this is on Twitter
okay and but then people would like
click that link and then go to her
profile and it's all her like having sex
ins oh thank you right and so I actually
gently like shared something and they're
like oh my god is that what is that
person you know now that you're divorced
I'm like not really I just like Harris
you okay he was kind of keep me here's
the thing these people though OS [ __ ]
yeah and it does
mean anything it's like yeah you're a
lot to watch porn a lot of people don't
you're no but a lot of people don't know
that I did Web Design in the late 90s
and when you did web design of the late
90s who are you designing websites where
you're designing websites for girls who
do porn you're doing it more like guys
who really like run industry run like a
what's the weirdest one you ever
designed ah nothing that nothing right
like I did one of the guys I worked with
I built a couple front ends for him
Donnie Donnie's girls I think was his
website and then he ended up like
deleting and all and became a very
devout Christian preacher so that's
probably the most interesting story
right yet so it's not like you know but
I mean you would you talk to the girls
who do sex work and who cares like you
do sex work for a living awesome that's
great and I don't know like like some
Christians like get upset about and
that's fine because their Center if you
don't like that that makes sense in this
like some in cells and I don't like
using that word but like some people who
are not able to like you know get what
they want with women they get like super
mad about sex workers and like the
slut-shaming of stuff why those are the
girls who might [ __ ] you one day most of
them still may not that's true right but
the the girls who are willing to to do
sex work if you've got money who knows
you never know not that doesn't
represent 98% of them there are hookers
out there why are you mad at the girl
who shows their body because at least
you're getting to see their body why are
you mad at the girl has sex on camera
ladies at least they're having sex and
you get to see it you're participating
it in some way like what makes you angry
about that I don't know I think it's
that if they called that girl that
girl's gonna say no but that's true of
99% of girls right well no I mean most
girls aren't having sex with you just
calm down
right the insult phenomenon is is 100
that done recently originally meant
someone even knew it originally meant
like somebody who was physically or
mentally unable to create a relationship
specifically a physical one so it might
be somebody with standing wheelchair
paralyzed what does it stand for
voluntary sellable yeah right and now it
like they're just applying it to all the
Nerds from out there well there was like
an NFL subreddit that was like real
nasty right and like and then there's
like the the waffle a shooter was like
part of that community was like part of
the insult community right and self
proclaimed when it's and that's when it
really virally yeah and so like a lot of
people are
that moniker which originally meant just
people who are physically you know
unable right yeah right are like
mentally unable to or just you know and
now it's just like people who like don't
want to put in the work to take a nice
shower and put on some deodorant and
like get a job here we got a call from
Nathan he has a friend who was
embarrassed to go to the gym I guess
because they're overweight and he wants
some advice of let's check in with
Nathan hello how are you
god bless oh hey guys how's it going
Amy so what's the situation first of all
like thanks for having me on
hi yeah and yeah I'm so basically xxx
ten Tachyon died man and I'm just really
upset about that but the only wanted to
say okay that is not related at all to
the conversation but rest in peace to
xxx yeah I've never heard of him that he
died yeah and I got killed in like a
gang-related shooting or something or I
guess it was gang-related
I personally sometimes people die and
everybody's talking about it and
sometimes I don't even know anything
about them and this is one of those
cases I went and listened to one of the
songs was nice sad mmm I'm like oh man
that guy was good deep like that's why I
really like the style but it was a deep
those good lyrics [ __ ] that's sad I
really don't know what happened with
that one but I will say they and in turn
first ever we knew it was gonna happen
we let's just say this is kind of an
occasion that was our first troll
actually so hey I knew it I knew it
would be me too some guy is gonna like
champion and on the subreddit that was
somebody that was a troll thanks for
calling us slightly but I was then I
slightly cha ok I got a pic for I got a
pic pick wisely now we got Eric here
Eric's like I did this is real but now I
choose to troll Eric lost 250 pounds on
a vegan diet
hell yeah that's America god bless hello
so I didn't lose 50 pounds I was at 250
pounds and I've dropped to 200
okay he lost 40 40 large and over what
period in February since February oh
yeah that's good great
so what's the deal that you are you are
what are you here to sell us on veganism
pretty much but I'm sold on the veganism
all right all right I'm a vegan now he's
not a done deal
well that was great and you're crashing
it back there I will tell you I know
there's people in my group who are doing
like the gastric bypass surgery recovery
via vegan and it's all about the beans
it's all about the protein and it works
for them what do you I'm cured what do
you eat mostly okay and all the chicken
in the world what kind of how do you
cook it tend to grill at home I mean a
lot of chicken a lot of salmon too and
tend to grill at home or grill some same
at home do some asparagus on the side
this is Russell sprouts that's right and
that's like 80% when I eat and then when
I go to these parties at like and
YouTube's like would you like a lobster
roll wrapping caviar I'm like well [ __ ]
okay yeah all right that's fine but
otherwise it's just like and what what
do you weak to sugar so low and it it
still makes me feel awful to do it but
my brain is like ooh you remember when
used to set down a birthday cake and it
wasn't anybody's birthday yeah like
happy birthday like no but then like
I'll go to a birthday party and I'm like
oh god I really want to slice a cake
right or or you and you're not I like as
your doctor has you you're not supposed
to touch the stuff where you can be like
I don't have a little body so they go in
if you like a lot of really smart
recovery stuff and they're like okay so
you're gonna screw up right it's going
to be fourth of July there's a cookout
some of your favorite foods there and
you're gonna eat because it's a holiday
and you're surrounded by family and
everybody's eating and you're gonna do
it okay so number one listen your body
listen to the surgery all right you're
gonna get full way quicker than you so
when you're eating bad foods when your
body says we're full you stop okay
don't you for pleasure that's right
right so how has it been because I have
a tendency of overeating Rick how has it
been like listening to the sick it's
great I thought it's gonna be the worst
thing in the world I thought my body
would my
brain would say eat more eat more in my
body would say we can't it's the
opposite my brain is full or quicker and
so they explain really physics behind it
interesting so my stomach was the size
of a football
mm-hmm and the stretch receptors at that
point on the stomach basically could
never get triggered and that stretch
receptor tells the brain on the top of
your stomach this little nerve bundle on
the stoppage stomach to tell your other
brain to start producing the full
chemicals in the satisfaction
satisfaction chemicals I wasn't able to
do that anymore but once they made my
stomach real small the stretch receptors
get hit really easy mm-hmm and so my
brain gets triggered way quicker and
it's like hey that was great man I
really enjoyed that
that's right credit and so it just makes
it easy you just gotta listen to your
brain
you guys listen your body and stop
listening to the addiction and you
you'll be fine so when I do make a
mistake and I do I go to a party and I'm
just like you know what today or order
the wrong thing off the menu
I can't even it makes me a little bit
ill I don't enjoy it as much as I used
to unfold very quickly and it it's been
a good checks and balances system so
when you don't enjoy it as much does it
also eventually become something that
causes a real change like you're not
interested in right when I finally let
in and I'm like let's just do it and my
brain is like why did we do that yeah
and like you're right why did we do that
and then I just don't want to do it as
much than that so it makes it a little
easier to say now are you getting tired
of chicken kind of but I don't I'm
trying to think of it as just fuel
mm-hmm you know I'm just trying to think
of that if you can really like click
that in your mind and the thing that
there a lot of my groups have talked
about is you just got to think okay so
today is fuel day today I'm just gonna
eat the fuel that my body needs to go I
don't I don't need to masturbate with my
mouth which is basically what eating
good food filter right right so you're
giving yourself some pleasure in your
mouth make yourself momentary pleasure
that right amounts to nothing right or
words and so I don't need to
masturbating today but you know what on
Friday I'll get laid on Friday I'm gonna
go to the Walmart and I'm I'm gonna go
to the [ __ ] the theater I'm gonna get
the popcorn I'm gonna get the candy I'm
gonna dump the candy in the popcorn I'm
have a real good jerk-off session while
I watch the Marvel movie and then
Saturday it's back to fuel and that's
how I'm trying to realign my image of
masturbating in the mouth yeah doing
roasts art analogy because it is this
all about you but you put the cut
candy in the popcorn you get a malted
milk balls you don't yeah and like I can
get the small popcorn and that's too
much popcorn now which is great but a
really UK national a small popcorn so
what's the one that you pour in the
popcorn what's the malted milk balls
whatever you get like the whopper or the
Maltesers or whatever it oh they're so
good I've done that I did that doesn't
it get nasty with your oh yeah it's a
really gross you already getting butter
you get chocolate that looks like you
both jerk yourself off that's that's
been my like I tried to socialize a lot
a lot of my friends are fatties and so
like we go out to eat and they're like
order and all like the craziest [ __ ] and
I'm trying to eat when you say fatty
it's like like I know some for
500-pounders man and like I guess I
think it's like I'm just a matter of
like gravitational pole I think I think
we don't really like each other it's
just like we can't break this right but
no like we're close friends and like I
have my biggest friend I think is 550 I
think he said
and so he's where I was and like he's
he's working on the process now and got
a couple of friends here about my size
now I got a couple friends are smaller
and then I got a few skinny friends too
but like what everybody likes to eat so
and I reconnected one of my friends who
I hadn't seen since I got married my
ex-wife didn't like them so they just
never got along so and we never saw each
other and we started going out to the
movies once a week and he actually got
the gastric bypass surgery as well and
got down to 350 to smallest and he's
back up like 400 now and that's where
he's just gonna be for the rest of his
life I think you do you think like when
you get the gastric bypass and you then
you always lose a bunch of weight right
if you start going up again is that
almost like statistically here's exactly
what'll happen you lose a certain
percentage you'll get to your ideal
weight they told me that wait for me be
about 270 mm-hmm then I would put on 10%
of my current body weight at that time
so another twenty seven thirty pounds
then that's where I will naturally be
pretty much into London but never your
bottom Ellis right so right but they're
talking and and they're like look after
that year and a half we're talking you
need to be in the gym four hours a day
mm-hm well you need to be killing it you
need to be active you need to be a very
very active person who doesn't sit down
who doesn't do your job who doesn't you
gotta be his
are you need to start biking you need to
start walking you start running you need
to be in the pool you have to if you
want to get smaller than that you're
going to have to be as active as it
comes and I want to be like after
setting down for 20 years right and now
that I'm up and walking again I'm up on
my feet all day every day and you get me
back in the swimmin pool I'm gonna be in
there three hours a day I don't give a
damn right up put on those little
underwater earphones and all this in the
shitty like [ __ ] mumble rap or
whatever it'll swim on this podcast not
come out was done and and I just man I'm
just so tired of sitting there it's so
tired of not doing things you know and
sorry I feel like I hope I'm gonna be
that guy I'm gonna try to be that guy do
you know what's the percentage of people
that like rebound very small I agree can
you google it you'd be very surprised
it's a really hard surgery to rebound
you uh you because you're pretty much
stuck on that that you know eight ounces
of food ten ounces but some people might
get as much as twelve once you get to
like almost a full plate of food you're
eating the wrong plate of food every day
yet you will regain them you have like I
ran a I heard of somebody I know who
knows somebody that said that they had a
gastric bypass yeah and they were at a
point where they were just like chugging
milkshakes because they couldn't eat a
lot I actually know somebody who they
were I don't know what Akal what it was
that they just craved yeah this I know
somebody who literally eight months
after eight weeks after the surgery was
eating ice cream for every meal because
that was his favorite food and he did
not do the the mental prep work first
and if you don't do the mental prep work
you're gonna fail well you're basically
going to battle with a brutal addiction
right and like that's that was the
biggest thing like when my ex-wife you
know at the the six eight week mark
she's just like look I gotta do this I'm
sorry and I love you and I'll always
love you and it sucks and I'm so sorry
to do this but this is how it has to be
I've got people who need me I got [ __ ] I
got to do I'm sorry so did she surprise
you kind of out of the blue with that we
had a couple years of the last two years
was not perfect and what you know man I
probably should never even say this
publicly but I think she'd forgive me
and even if she doesn't we're divorced
now so I don't have to worry about it
but um we're in a loop in which my
anxiety was so bad
that she was kind of walking on
eggshells all the time because she was
afraid of
scaring me upsetting me hurting me hmm
and that the way she reacted to my
anxiety was very frequently with
fight-or-flight and for her that mostly
meant fight so I would become anxious
over something and when I become anxious
I'd become a little angry I'm a little
edgy not abusive or any stretching
nation I was like I need to focus on
this right now I need to be left alone
let me focus on this Yeah right and that
would be enough to make her feel bad and
then when she would feel bad she would
become angry or upset or anxious or sad
or whatever and so then that would make
me feel more anxious and that would make
I mean we ended up like this like I know
exactly what you mean and so what we
really needed to do honestly to save it
about a year ago or a year and a half
ago we needed to start intense therapy
we needed to separate a little bit and
not be asked codependent and find that
space again between us and we weren't
able to do that because she was my
physical caretaker right so she we
didn't have that option and that's
that's just what killed it and like you
can have every theory in the world about
my ex-wife left and you're gonna have
every theory in the world that she
cheated on me or she's only there for
the money or anything like that but none
of it's true it all just really comes
down to it sounds like it wasn't that my
morbid obesity and and my more would
have easily killed our marriage and my
bad eating habits my she decisions that
led me to that lifestyle
it just killed a reg that's it and you
know I could be as mad at her as I
wanted to be but you know she could
easily left in July when we first
started to talk about it before I got
the surgery leaving me to a point where
I could have never got it yeah instead
she she buckled down and she did her
wifely duty and carried me that nice
nice you're getting a lot of credit and
right and I'm like nice you know and
I'll be honest you know when she finally
had to leave I was still recovering from
surgery that's true and she gonna made
another three to six months out have
been great mm-hmm but she couldn't and
that's fine she made it as long as she
did and boy it was more than I think I
deserve so I don't know it's it's hard
to be upset because she told me do God's
say
she told me she's like you know one of
these days you're gonna thank me freely
and like [ __ ] you're full of [ __ ]
mmm um but about three months ago I hit
that point I was like you know she was
right she's happier I'm happier I'm
recovering still everything's going okay
everything's going great for her and
this is the right move and I'm glad that
she did because all I ever really wanted
if the first was for her to be happy
okay I get emotional I'm sorry all I
really wanted for her was to be happy
and I'm like if you need to go then go
I'm not gonna fight you on it let me cut
you a nice big Chuck you just go and
take care of your life and that's fine
um and I wasn't worried about me I
wasn't thinking about me I was just
thinking about her and I think sometimes
in a marriage maybe that's becomes
natural to do that you know like I'm
just moved mostly worried about the
person that's worried about me mm-hmm
I wasn't taking to account that she
wasn't worrying about me anymore that
she's you know pulling out but anyway um
and then I discovered I was happy and
I'm like wow this is really weird
and I probably shouldn't be right now
but I'm like up and walking and meeting
people and hanging out and having new
experiences and travel in the country
and and making plenty of money and and
have this wonderful audience is so
dedicated to me and they're there for me
every night on Twitter what I feel alone
and there's every night whenever you
know I I need that [ __ ] when I'm on
stream and I'm just like what do I have
to be pissed off about mm-hmm right like
my life is really good and it's better
than it's ever been
yeah so [ __ ] it why be mad what's yeah
what was the how was the was it like a
50% divorce kind of situation yeah
that's that's how it works in Arkansas
and and so like she's legally entitled
to 50% of everything we own like stocks
and bonds and whatever was that messy it
really wasn't um we talked about it one
day and uh you know and she agreed to
stay like for another month to make sure
everything was great and we gave it our
best effort in that month to see what
she'd be missing yeah and I mean we
slept in the same bed we were very close
to in that month it was great but one
day we're talking about money and I'm
like what do you want she's like I want
what's right she don't she said she's
like I want what's fair yeah and I'm
like that's reasonable what is fair like
do I give you a lump sum do you want
alimony and she's like I don't know I
don't think I want alimony I'm like well
honey what's alimony alimony is where
you you continue to pay after you're
married because you owe or big right so
like I think and she could have made an
argument so the argument often for women
is I need to maintain a lot
especially if there's kids involved in
there's no kids involved yeah but she
could have also made the argument that
she helped build the business sure and
she never even attempted it and everyone
ever played dirty right and like one day
I was like you know even if you asked
for alimony I am the business you can't
on half of me and she's like that's a
good thing I don't want it then huh hmm
and she's like yeah I want enough to
where I know I'm gonna be taken care of
for a good while that's all I worry
about mmm and I'm like okay so she gave
me a number and I'm like but that's not
half and she's like what do you mean
it's not it wasn't half of what we were
it was less it was less and so I talked
to my lawyer and I'm like what do i do
do I just give her that amount he goes
you sure rounded up you just make sure
it's you make sure it's half so she has
no recourse moving for me just to be
great and I'm like all right so that's
where you asked where here's what you're
actually getting it's quiet okay thank
you
I should never question it and like
that's not what we're worth worth more
let me show you the numbers let's sat
down let me show you everything and then
this way you're gonna get you do you own
your house yeah so you're so you're
factoring in like the value of your home
right so I got the equity of and that we
put into the house right and had to like
there was all the liquid cash and stuff
right and they're like when it came to
like I have some money in crypto not a
lot you know not one of these crypto
crypto millionaires but I was like when
we're doing mediation I'm like so what
about the crypto she's like it's so
volatile don't worry about it that's
kind of true and I'm like okay for half
a crypto and you're gonna be bright yeah
and she's like it's so volatile don't
worry about it you can keep that and
I'll let that be your nest egg if it
works out great have it doesn't--it okay
- sounds like she was a real a real she
really was man like it is Bora but and
that's the worst part about it um she
said something once she's like the key
to doing this is just is to leave when I
still love you mmm damn and I'm like but
honey that's why you stay like that's
what you fight for cuz we do love each
other and it's just like I know that and
but here's the thing it's not working
right and and and love is not going to
fix that right other it's just not gonna
work and eventually we're gonna be
better eventually are gonna be angry at
each other eventually gonna be at each
other's throats and I don't want to do
that and you don't want to do that you
can't survive that safe with schedules
you're so let's not do that okay I'm
gonna leave while I still love you and
that way it can be good and we hit
friends and we still talk you know
that's really sweet
I honestly and it's a girl was
heartbreak [ __ ] I'm bus Oh hard for both
of us oh I think harder for her at times
you know because she's the one having to
pull off the bandage
I heard the pull off the band-aid god
help her but she's recovering well and
proud of her what's like how was the the
process of actually getting divorce it
seems so messy did you both have an
attorney
Oh quick and easy actually you guys had
the rare right the rare beautiful
everybody's yeah it was basically like
we could have a waited 18 months
um but neither was wanted to and so we
went to our lawyer and we're like so you
had one lawyer yeah so we don't the
mediator okay
and we're like so how do we do this
quickly and he goes well she'll sign
away her rights to appear in court she
can go back to Michigan and then you
know Cory you're nothing yeah you can
you can be there for 30 seconds the
judge will sign your piece of paper
you're good and well like I sued her for
divorce because it was just more
convenient that way what's this whole
thing about sue yeah that's the right
thing you really information for divorce
and you list your grievances right yeah
and so the the grievance we went with in
the state of Arkansas was there is an
indignity that made the marriage not
content not possible to continue and so
indignities and like just like something
like I guess if someone cheated on
somebody or somebody physically beat
somebody or something happened did it no
nothing like that happened so the
indignity when the judge asked me what
the indignity was I said she asked for a
divorce
that's the indignities in dignity that I
could not survive yeah she wanted to
leave and I said for I have to defend me
so much that I want to be divorced
because she wants to be a divorce why
does it have to be so you do that
instead of Arkansas they don't what
you're getting divorce in the state of
Arkansas they don't you take your unions
very [ __ ] seriously so like as I
understand it and you can correct me if
I'm wrong because you've been through it
but like if a husband cheats on a wife
she can sue him for divorce for an for
for cheating and so she gets a better
settlement right in the divorce right
and in the state of Arkansas they told
me that I did not want it to appear in
front of a lawyer because the judges in
the state of Arkansas start at 50% and
then
higher for the woman crazy right there
like there without it over 50% for him
see percent for women every time in the
state of Arkansas that and she knew that
surely if she consulted with a single
lawyer he'd have been like we get again
we can get eighty nine percent of what
is worth it oh yeah that you have to be
kind of vindictive to go that route yes
or so to be like not only my leaving you
but I'm gonna destroy you financially
yeah I'm gonna take everything so how
has it been losing 50% of your I mean
well you guys were married quiet I don't
say but like you you you you have 50%
less was that like number in my head and
most youtubers like spend this much on
[ __ ] breakfast okay but I had a
number in my head that if I get to that
number in the bank account it doesn't
matter what I do from then on out I'm
taking care of it my current lifestyle
for about 10 years okay and I won't live
that much longer so I'll be fine
I can get that number in the bank I will
be fine and I got that number in the
bank about two and a half months before
the surgery mm-hmm and I'm like so now
I'm ready for the surgery because even
if I
I can't work if I have a stroke here in
that surgery of a heart attack and their
whole business falls apart I'm okay for
the next decade she's taken care of I'm
taking care of the dogs taken care of in
that's all I have to take care of in the
world
mmm-hmm ten years hmm and then I get
through the surgery and then she's like
so look I need to start a new life and
I'm gonna need help doing it and I'm
like [ __ ]
so the good news is I'm killing it with
brand manager with my brand manager I'm
killing it with twitch that's all
filling with YouTube numbers are down
money is you're making here are you
making more right now than you have ever
previous oh yeah I'm making about 50
percent more than I made last year I'm
just because before you weren't the
right thing I wasn't physically able to
do the job I was able to physically
stream as off that I was able to
physically travel I was gonna be able to
do the pilots right that your business
is doing well and so it's like it's
weird because I look at the numbers on
YouTube and everybody stresses over it
right and I'm used to X number reviews
and now I'm down about 20% views but it
doesn't matter because even the had
senses up for me a lot a YouTube red is
up for me a lot and then the brand
manager my brand manager you know he's
how many brand deals do you do a month
about four I'm gonna four so you do
about as many in a podcast as I do in a
month but yeah but
well yes but I mean it's different
because I think the rates are different
when my share of the spot right then I
do like most I push for CPA now because
my audience is so incredibly engaged or
is a lot more for YouTube channel that's
a lot and it's just in my weekly show
and just do a weekly show and and we
drive home for solid once a month and
it's all stuff that I actually use you
know I'm advertising your company I will
use it for a month before I'll talk
about it and like you got to send me
product you got to give me access to the
service I'll use it for a month
sometimes I pay for it so they don't
know it's like a dummy account like
you're interacting with people there and
and then I'm like at the end of that
month I'm like if it's good enough and I
turned down more than I've said yes to I
think at this point nice because it's
always stuff that I know my audience
will use yeah I agree to one thing one
time that I didn't think was a good fit
I really liked it was like a financial
app and it was really helping me but a
lot of my audience is like broke gamers
right and there's don't have a lot of
money that I have to manage and if they
manage it it's how much is my xbox lives
version this month right so I don't I
didn't think there's gonna be a good fit
and it turned out not to be a good fit
great product not a good fit and that's
the only time I've ever but when it
works made it work yes it's where I push
for cpa because my audience takes really
good care of me and i only bring them
you have cpa yeah i try to do the
seafood bills every time that's
interesting i wouldn't i would never
choose to do that because right makes me
feel like i don't like to be sure to
explain the term for anyone means that
cost-per-acquisition so it means boogie
he makes money for every sign up so
people come i guess there's two
different ways of youtuber can do a
brand deal one is that so every time
someone kind signs up using his link he
gets a certain commission right and
about half of my deals are still still
like just fixed pay from the spot fixed
fixed I come will give you X number of
dollars just to give this a shot on the
video and then we're gonna sink or swim
based on that and if we do better or do
well enough it then will resolve a
gamble for them but it's more for me
it's more of the consistency and I
frankly I think that there's a lot more
to doing a spot than just the numbers
right like if you go do a commercial on
television
these people have no feedback they have
no idea exactly you roll a Toyota
commercial drink Jimmy Kimmel
who knows how many Toyotas you sold but
it's about the brand recognition exactly
so I think that when you're selling
yourself CPA first of all sometimes CPA
can make you more if Reta first right
but I think that it discounts half of
what you're really doing for that brand
which I putting the name in people's
brains since since this is your podcast
I won't mention brand but I worked with
one brand that was a super natural fit
in fact we're filming a little something
at VidCon this week and that go up
probably next month but it was such a
natural fit it paid like five months
worth of my mortgage and just really it
was like such a good if it was a hybrid
deal too so they paid for the spot and
then once you got past X number of sales
they paid for like a CPA deal that's
just stupid ly good it was like such a
good natural fit it was such a good
product and don't you hate this right
this this whole sellout thing because
when you find a good sponsor and yeah
and in your case you're like my number
I'm on a downswing right but I'm doing
better than ever right that's so [ __ ]
beautiful yeah it's great
mio needs to be honest with you I
thought my audience is going to rebel
and they did when I first started doing
brand deals because I was doing game
based brand deals and I had a company
come to me III you know because I don't
want to talk about numbers because
depending on the youtuber some numbers
are huge some numbers are small but they
came to me and they're like hey look if
you like what you used to work for free
here to do a mobile game shout out will
you do our mobile game I won't pressure
you to say but feel free to well it was
is well no [ __ ] you don't hire I'm not
going to good I wanna make anybody angry
like some people is gonna sound like a
huge number and other people is gonna
smell like a small number but so that's
where I get a quite a few mortgage
payments out of it is it's enough to
where I was like Jesus Christ really
yeah uhm and so they're like I'm like
what do you want we're on a 30-second
spot out with a 30-second shout-out two
minutes in to your gaming new series
mm-hmm and I'm like Jesus that's like
five times what somebody would normally
pay you people are insane so any schism
but the problem is it's a game and I'm a
game critic and it's a gaming though
show that's right conflict right and so
right so I used to get flown up by
Ubisoft all the time I used to get flown
out by EA one of the work with you at
some point used to get flown up by Sony
and we were doing all these great deals
they put you up at a nice hotel they
take fire to the parties you gonna meet
the game developers you have the
best time in your [ __ ] life and then
I can also here's a big fat check thank
you very much for just talking about our
game right but then when I talk about
Playstation next week they're like is he
being honest though mm-hm because he
doesn't want to burn that bridge yeah
and so they were like that I just I
basically had to abandon it I thought I
would never have another brand deal
again but then I talked to somebody who
worked with another youtuber I trusted
that youtuber put in a referral and and
then it's just been off to the races and
that's awesome and the numbers just keep
going higher and higher and and I think
a lot of it's because I I don't know my
audience is very engaged is such an
incredible loving supportive audience
I'm just shocked by it and everyday and
then I get to meet them at like next
week at VidCon even though last year's
VidCon was a living hell for me we'll
talk about that if you want yeah but you
know I got to write the easier and we
can talk about the who but uh but like
getting to meet the fans man at e3 I
thought it's gonna be able to do a lot
more at e3 than I was gonna be able to
but it turns out I just sat and shook
hands for 45 minutes to an hour at a
time and it's the best feeling in the
world because my fans are so engaged I
also met a lot of you get down on
yourself a lot but like yeah your fan I
agreed that your fans are super engaged
yeah the last episode we did together is
one of our most popular I was like two
and half million views which is insane
for a podcast right and this episode
just right now in their live view
thousand dude that's one of the top five
I can't believe maybe even tossing three
that's guys I I think there's a lot of
people out there somebody said to me my
channel last in the last year was like a
[ __ ] slow motion car wreck they're
like I couldn't look away and I don't
know if you were gonna die in the car
accident or your life was gonna get
speared right I wanted to see how it
happened man right and that's all up on
the channel somebody wants to go watch
me talk about my divorce in slow motion
or talk about the weight loss or see me
on a reality show
yes and I'm like yeah I guess I get that
but I didn't I didn't really want to be
a spectacle but here's the thing if
people can learn from my mistakes is
they can learn from my divorce that they
can learn from my surgery if they can
fix their [ __ ] and and and at least not
make the same stupid mistakes I made
it's a life well-lived
right absolutely yeah so I I don't I
have no problems opening up as wide as I
can and showing everything that I can if
I'm just some like weird-looking freak
show to you that's okay because at least
you got a laugh out of it but if we find
something here that's useful in
your life that's the best feeling in the
world right and that's what my fans were
saying so I was laying in bed when I
brought a friend with me to e3 and he
says to me goes mm I said what I guess
that's the number of pounds just today
people have told you that they've lost
really and I guess and that's just
people said it and like you would even
keep on tracking us no I was just trying
to add it up and I think it's right
about 2,000 pounds maybe 29 that's
that's Finnick you know they like you
what you're going through
yeah and your whole journey is something
this so many people are looking and you
get to you get people who criticize
rings like he shows that it's okay to be
fat and I'm like that's the ice into my
glances my messages
it's so not okay look at this life that
I'm leading and I can't enjoy because my
fat yeah right I'm not a body positivity
person and in that you should love your
body but you should also try to change
it for the better
what is it that people misunderstand
about being like morbidly obese right
like you've been on that side you see
how people react you're a reasonable
same guy so like mmm like you're you're
grounded enough to to comment on it I
don't know what I mean I I think a lot
of people I I think a lot of people
don't really understand that someone who
eats themselves somebody it's like a
fifty pounds overweight they're lazy
they like food you can write down
several weight you're really lazy and
you really like food right you get two
to 300 pounds overweight something's
[ __ ] wrong you might have an injury
maybe or maybe you're eating to die
yeah and you get two three four five
hundred pounds overweight that's
somebody who's been molested that's
straight up I can tell you that
everybody don't think that damaging or
you just saying like it's almost it's
almost exclusively noise I'm so
surprised it's like 90 percent like
studies about that I don't sure they're
done I'm sure they are buddies like that
somebody who's like carrying some real
[ __ ] damage yeah nobody does that
right nobody drinks themselves to a
gutter why do you know what I did it
what is it about you know the malla or
what is it about the food that like I
think I think when it comes to
molestation I think the phenomenon is
because you received
sexual attention you did not want and so
since we desexualize morbid obesity
there's someone who's fat is on a track
[ __ ]
they they make a either subconscious or
even conscious choice to make themselves
unattractive and I've seen studies like
that seen books write about that and I
think I think I think that's a very real
possibility I don't think that's what I
was doing I think I was just trying to
eat to die I was just suicidal and I'm
like this is they would tell me when I
was like 25 they'd be like if you keep
eating the way you eat you'll be dead at
30 and I'd be like awesome there's a
buffet on the way home some are [ __ ]
hit that [ __ ] because I would like to be
doing that conscious about yeah it's
like straight up I was like that's
awesome news thanks doc I appreciate you
I'll see if I can get that done was
there a point where you're like wait a
minute I want to live yeah like 35 36
and the the YouTube thing started taking
off when I feel audience yeah like I met
a girl that I really liked that I
thought I was gonna be with forever and
I'm like I know together man like holy
Sh I have an opportunity to find an
audience exactly yeah I found an
audience and they cared about me and I
had friends that cared about me and a
girl that cared about me and I'm like
this is a real chance this is the thing
I've been holding on for this is the
thing I was hoping for this is the thing
that I kept telling everybody else like
you know when I talk to somebody else's
suicide I'm like just wait just wait and
see something good luck yeah just wait
and see and then that that thing
happened and I'm like holy [ __ ] they
were all right I waited and here it is
now I gotta get my [ __ ] together and it
still took me seven years to get the
guys how [ __ ] up I was it still took
me seven mm-hmm and I'm still a
400-pound man so I still have a shitload
of things to fix you know but I'm on the
process what kind of activities are you
doing now that you're enjoying now that
you can like never you know a year or
two ago I mean Quoddy sex got way better
no not having a lot of it but what the
quality went over that yes just walking
the dog was one of the first big
achievements and you know just being
able to take him around the block a
couple times and and then hide the other
day after starting physical therapy I've
been out for about four weeks and I got
out of bed and normally when I would get
out of bed it's set immediately down and
I would just sit there and grunt while I
waited for my muscle relaxers to kick it
and stuff but the dog wanted outside so
I let him out back and I noticed he'd
taken a toy outside so I went back to
God get it I leaned down to pick it up
and I picked it up and I was like my
brain goes oh no no no we shouldn't be
leaning over
mm-hm and I'm like no we're fine though
and then I was leaning over it was
simple I yeah so I let him in the house
and I led the dog into the house and I
sat down on my chair I'm like I'm more
uncomfortable setting than I am standing
right now what the [ __ ] is going on so I
stood up I started my physical therapy
exercises I had no pain killers that had
nothing and I started walking around the
house I did a couple of chores and
started a little laundry and then sat
down and like huh that's weird so it's
like it the big stuff is great
you know going to Disney maybe this
weekend and then being able actually
enjoy it or or being able to walk up on
stage without feeling embarrassed or or
looking in the mirror not throwing up
except when I look at my terrible teeth
but um you know like that stuff but it's
the it's the little stuff it's just the
tiniest little quality of life things
you know it's just something that you
still look forward to like you're like
man if I could just do this one little
day i buy clothes off the rack one day
yeah that's it's gonna be a while you
know I still use like the only place I
could find the head clothes my size as a
place called king-sized rack
mmm they still sell like 9x clothes 9 X
9 X is what said to you I'm wearing 4x
everything now yeah 4 X's are a little
tight up top so the I brought a lot of
my larger shirts to VidCon this is like
a 6 and look at it it's a joke you know
but I I feel like a little
self-conscious in the the upper region
because of the old man tits those aren't
going away anytime soon so there's gonna
be a period of time I'm shaped like a
dick you know but that's fine do you
feel do you feel like people hate fat
people oh yeah straight up and you ever
felt like just like pure like animosity
from people they had absolutely and I
mean not just like I mean plenty there's
like plenty of internet people but every
if you're on the internet you get used
to him hated right there yeah um but
they're people in real life I went to a
Walgreens in the middle of the night one
night and I was like fighting off a cold
so I got like some more shoes and I got
some cold medicine and I got a chocolate
bar and I tell the guy I'm like hey man
how you doing night he said I'm doing
all right
it's tough night I'm like yeah I'm sick
of [ __ ] because yeah a lot of people are
right now some of them not by choice
and he said that as he's ringing up my
candy bar and I'm like [ __ ]
dude like [ __ ] you I have the [ __ ]
flu you can't tell me like [ __ ] you you
say anything yeah like I was like hey
that's cool man I suck I talk to your
manager I go for what and what you know
what I'll wait at home I'll call and I
call the manager and the manager took
that guy side he's like he's like sir
you are very obese and I'm like it's not
how I expected this to go so I guess
I'll just hang up that's crazy
all right you know I one time was in
Memphis Tennessee and it's right after
that theater I was dating was convinced
me that it would be okay I can't shop at
Walmart dearly but I want you to go to
the wall or I think they have motorized
scooters you need to use them I can't
physically I don't you know I be
comfortable in those things I don't know
they can carry me let's try it this is
like second time ever trying one of
these things that a guy gets behind me
it's got like his shitty old flip phone
from 2005 but he's like following me
behind he's filming me and he's like
look at this big [ __ ] look at
hide never seen nobody this big we got a
big this mother fundraise II write good
and but I get it to some extent because
you you perceive it as gluttony and you
perceive it as selfishness and you
perceive it as laziness and you perceive
it as because they don't all these
terrible negative trait I don't relate
at all to what you're actually right you
don't perceive it as coping one day you
don't wait that's because they let
themselves go for a week you know people
don't perceive it as coping they don't
perceive it as dealing with the
molestation they don't perceive it as
addiction they don't perceive it as that
right and that's true of homeless people
a lot of people find homeless people
contemptible you know you look some of
the numbers and they say that you know
actual homeless people not necessarily
you know your your guy on the street
corner with a cell phone in his hand you
know but like the actual people in New
York who's sleeping a [ __ ] gutter
most of them have mental illnesses in
course so we think of most disgusting
dirty people that's the thing a lot of
people just don't not very good at
empathy I'm not that great I don't
honestly so I can't blame them it's
tough you know it's hard to think about
anybody outside of ourselves but hey I
think if you really ever sat down and
talked to a person who sighs you'll
understand where they're coming from and
there's plenty of people out there doing
me a great [ __ ] disservice by like
all this hell that any sighs [ __ ] [ __ ]
like seriously [ __ ] well the these
these are like as predominately like
plus-size models who are
like don't don't tell me like that being
fat is unhealthy or they'll say stuff
like that or this or that being fat is
is beautiful or whatever are overweight
and there are people out there who find
fat very beautiful and that's great and
you're right you are beautiful to some
extent and you're still another person
and that is beautiful and that's all
great but understand that what you're
doing is absurdly unhealthy yeah they're
damaging your organs your damage your
bones you're gonna suffer tremendously
in your late 30s early 40s and you'll be
dead by 50 so the whole healthy at every
site well it's like almost oxymoronic
like healthy at every Sun now it's like
it's just not a thing it's just not a
thing and I'm sorry do they really
believe that I I don't know I honestly
don't know I think there's there's a
certain amount of self delusion you have
to go through to be a certain size and
to do that stuff and maybe there is some
level of that I'm all for body
positivity to some extent I'm all for
others yeah the difference between me
and like I'm healthy at 400 pounds and
like please don't film me right right
and they're like if you're 500 pounds
and you're like you know what I want to
change but I don't hate myself mm-hmm I
think that's a very positive right yeah
but if you're 500 pounds you're like I
love being 500 pounds of 500 pounds as
who and what I want to be and I don't
give a [ __ ] about the health
ramifications I don't give a [ __ ] about
the fact that I'm dying I don't give a
[ __ ] about it that's not healthy yeah
that's that's crazy you're being crazy
stop yeah you know it's I don't know
it's tough man it's it's I it's fine
most people are empathetic most people
are kind you got to concentrate them on
the the healthy people especially as a
youtuber or anything you do in life at
your job whatever you know at school
whatever you're dealing with there's
gonna be plenty of people in this world
who don't like you oh yeah I mean the
mass majority of people will never know
who the [ __ ] you are or give a [ __ ] yeah
there's gonna be a small number of
people in this world that give a [ __ ]
about you you got to concentrate on the
people who give a [ __ ] about you that's
the only people that matter right
somebody [ __ ] despises you or hates
you or [ __ ] whatever they don't like
the way you do your job they don't like
the way you create content they don't
like you as a person there's a family
member doesn't like him [ __ ] him his
third problem deal with it kill your
[ __ ] problem it's not mine I'm gonna
be me yeah I'm gonna love that people
who love me that's great
any Chet any Chet said if you don't so
let's let's talk about VidCon last year
whoo the great notorious Anita
sarkeesian and I got [ __ ] from both
sides I got
[ __ ] from Anita selection let's let's
let's set the let's place the setting so
so what happened last year I get invited
to be on a panel for cyber bullying
which is a topic I talk about quite a
bit right and my premise for cyber
bullying has always been very simple
doesn't matter who you are you put
yourself out there you're gonna catch it
mm-hmm
when a woman says I catch it worse than
you I say probably but you know what
we're both getting it so we should both
work on it when a person of color since
I get it worse I say you're probably
right but we're both getting it yeah and
we should both work on it so your point
going into that panel
I mean people knew that was your
position right that's spoken and I think
VidCon knew and they asked me to be on
it is that I am here as a person I'm
gonna repeat the thing that got me in so
much trouble
mm-hmm but here I am setting in a place
of perceived privilege I am straight I'm
white I am male mm-hmm and you guys
think that makes me bulletproof right
but it doesn't yeah because I've had
people show up my front door to say
nasty [ __ ] to my face mm-hmm and I've
had to send boxes of [ __ ] to my front
door I've had him send black dildos
Macchio boxes boxes of shits by little
actual boxes of [ __ ] what did you open
it tell me about he sent it to the wrong
address they hit the wrong address got
leaked so is my friend's house and he's
like hey you got this in the mail
brought it to me
handed it to me I open it up and there's
a box of horseshit and they're like [ __ ]
you for Xbox or something like that I
think is Xbox related and somebody sent
me like a 12-inch dildo to the PIO box
it's like now you can finally satisfy
your wife enjoy consummating your
marriage with this thing yeah people are
frightening and so like you deal with
that [ __ ] and I do not doubt for a
second that plenty of women get it worse
yeah no and I don't not for a second
that a person to call you say that to me
I believe you got a reason not to
believe mm-hmm that's fine
but I i point on that panel is to say if
you're a straight white man you're in
this audience and you think you're
immune to it get to my level of
notoriety and you'll get [ __ ] too
well it's a good point and because
they're all about inclusion right right
there but now on what inclusion
sometimes results in is alienating right
the majority of the population which are
you know you get what is great white
males for example yeah and you get a lot
of what you call the oppression Olympics
right like no I have a worse know I have
always know I have worse yeah how about
this the human condition [ __ ] sucks
the world we've created a [ __ ] show
social media is [ __ ] destroying all
and we just work on that at a base level
and maybe we don't exclude the straight
white men who also could help how about
we don't exclude anybody how about we
got us work together yeah let's just do
that yeah that was my goal corner that
panel and Anita in my closing statements
that's basically word-for-word what I
said
and then we got offstage and she puts
her finger in my face and she's like I
don't forget appreciate what you [ __ ]
set up there knowing I didn't have a
chance to [ __ ] respond and I'm like
it was closing statements everybody got
a chance to come they went to you next
immediately I don't understand well like
what I originally told his site she's
boiling yeah actually straight-up
furious all right all right now that
this goal probably bullying but I mean
she's mad I mean she's got her finger in
your face how dare you just agree with
me I'm like look I have diagnosed
post-traumatic stress disorder I
depersonalized during moments of great
stress learning a lot of pain that panel
is very hard on me your now it's you
know got your finger in my face we need
to back off for a second because I might
say or do some stupid [ __ ] and I don't
want to do that okay so why don't we
talk about this right what were you
afraid of doing I don't know this is
firing back but my note finger at her
face screaming I don't want to speculate
it had a woman who's you know a quarter
of my weight I don't want to hurt
anybody I don't - screaming anybody yeah
you know and I think a lot of people
misperceived that is we don't want to
scream at her because she's so powerful
no I just she's a fellow human being I
don't ever want to be caught on video
much less actually screaming in the face
of another person I don't ever want to
reciprocate if somebody's mean to me I
don't wanna be mean back right but I
will do that when they do personalize
cuz I'll go into fight or flight and
then I'll let go and then I will call
her every name in the book I want to do
that yeah and so I'm like can we talk
about this somewhere safe and she's like
yep so we go backstage and I talk to her
for an hour and here's what I will say
and I think this is the thing that got
me in more trouble than anything I think
Anita sarkeesian's goals might be
genuine and I know that's hard for a lot
of people do you have to accept that oh
I think a lot of people feel that she's
like a con artist and they that she's
like just drifting maybe we should
explain who she is she's like how would
you describe her she's like a video game
journalist right and rezzak and she had
a series called feminist frequency and
she took like a bunch of GoFundMe money
or something like that to build the
series and there's like before she made
the series she said some things like I'm
not a
gamer I don't like video games yeah I
didn't like she was a you know now she's
like she's really good at waiting
install for this stuff that I've seen
her do was like really trashy misleading
stuff like she's walking through like a
hitman game and murdering stripper right
which is like not what you're supposed
to do right and then she's like look how
misogynist this game is you're murdering
what strippers right and it's like well
that's what you chose and she's bright
and she would very frequently like show
stuff like that the brilliant wait but
the to a gamer who's knowledgeable that
seems very misleading yeah there's
plenty of stuff that you could show that
actually might represent that point why
are you choosing this and I think a lot
of that had to do with the writers and
that she may not be that versed and
stuff like that that's all fly anyway
she's very controversial controversial
and I would say known for for being
quite right and a lot of her those kind
of a lot of people do not find her to be
genuine specifically for reasons like
that and having spoke with her for about
an hour well and her point is that she's
a feminist so she thinks that like
there's a ton of misogyny in video games
right and that's like it were six that
and like she would take like some of the
weirdest battles like miss pac-man
negatively reinforces female stereotypes
because she's the missus version of a
male character and like what the [ __ ]
like I don't know anything that man with
a [ __ ] bow right you know on but most
people agree with like some of her base
points like hey should there be an equal
number of female protagonists as male
protagonist sure why not okay why not so
my favorite game star female protagonist
let's do that more female protagonist
should they be sexy sometimes sure and
sometimes not that soaps okay who gives
a [ __ ] yeah whatever you want to do like
you're the game designer make a cool
game you know but like I think most
people would agree with her so she's
this controversy is only a point to make
it just like it depends how you do it
right and that's and I think that's her
biggest issue yeah her methodology is is
is very not right it's so it maybe not
even that it's so combative he's
opposite of what I did right really
breaking through he's more like divisive
I've always believed in boiling the Frog
right like I've always believed hey we
should have same-sex marriage I love
same-sex marriage let's do it but the
problem is we try to get it done right
now there's gonna be a huge backlash
okay so let's let's try to do it in 20
years in 10 years and let's see if we
can avoid the backlash right let's just
like slowly methodically change minds
I've always been a big fan of
slowly methodically changing minds
because I don't like it when gay people
get killed I don't like what somebody
gets murdered for being gay so let's not
rile up the [ __ ] crazies okay let's
just go slow and easy mm-hmm her
methodology is to rile up the crazies
get right in the face but a finger in
their faces I don't like [ __ ] what
you're [ __ ] saying and that's fine um
but I think I think after talking to for
an hour she on some level definitely
wants what best and doesn't understand
that our methodology is very poor mm-hmm
and maybe she's wrong about that and
that's entirely for your audience
society that's for Ohio's decide that's
fine here's what I can say I came out
thinking I just kind of feel bad for her
because I think that she you know wants
to build something great but it keeps
knocking it down herself every single
time and I'm just like okay I don't
really have a bone to pick with this
moment anymore because I just kind of
feel like bad and she hopefully she'll
figure it out you know hopefully she
forgot how to get an audience so she'll
figure out how to keep an audience and
hopefully she'll figure out something
that's very difficult to do which is
change people's minds right and so I
told her in this conversation is my
favorite conversation I had with her
I've said something in there it got you
in trouble which part oh maybe I missed
I said I said that um just even
recognizing that it was a straight white
male and that not that I personally
perceived that gives me privilege but
that I was trying to say you guys
perceive that it gives me privilege
right that's the label you put on me
right I don't know that it really
provides that much relish for me where
was it when I was homeless where was it
when I was growing up in poverty I don't
know I don't know what I was doing for
me then but okay if you believe that
know that it doesn't make me bulletproof
on this so anyway during the
conversation whether we talked about a
great number of things probably the most
frustrating thing she said to me she
said Steve people the reason you still
get that kind of hate whereas straight
white man would not it's because of your
morbid obesity that's what they're
attacking and like no they're attacking
me as a person come on like attacking me
as a person we all read we all catch it
right but again I don't know why she
wanted to minimalize me to that but I
was like I find that very well because
she's playing the oppression Olympics
right he's like yes sure you get bullied
I'm like I find that very minimalizing
and I use it it here's the thing yeah if
you're telling me that straight white
male is a magic bullet then that should
provide that should
me from having that problem right no
matter how morbidly obese I am it looks
that right we even say straight white
male skinny yeah is it straight white
male
yeah and that does not make me
bulletproof so I don't know what to tell
you I mean it's a frigate but we said
yeah we had we have yeah we said some
good stuff too and she said some some
pretty cool stuff and you know I think
it wasn't all bad but she she's she's
like what kind of audience do you have I
saw you meet you met with Sargon
yesterday I'm like yeah I talked to
Sargon once a woman it's not a terrible
guy I kind of agree with muscles [ __ ] he
says sometimes but that's fine think
people like her that's just not good as
like you said how she just it's so much
like them versus us right yeah I mean
I'm so really not like right so she's
like like I'm sure even if she sat down
with Sargon they could probably work out
some difference and that's the thing
I'll say my methodology a lot of people
don't agree with it okay here's the
thing I got an hour alone with Anita
sarkeesian you think Sargon said we're
gonna get an hour alone where she she
sat down and talked to me for a full
[ __ ] hour and listened to me and
heard me out and I'll tell you dismissed
everything I had to say but that's it
listen she listened Sargon's never gonna
get that sounds like I caused you so
much stress so bad even right now it was
like I thought ruin everything
it sounds like all you gave is just
another perspective look at a topic
you're like here's my perspective just
right and you know like I don't put any
of it on VidCon um and I don't put any
on Hank I don't put it on any of those
guys there was a bit some fallout like I
remember even VidCon tweeting about
there was all kinds of that whole panel
was [ __ ] was surrounding her was
dramatic oh yeah or the day before
Sargon showed up and said in the front
row and she decided to basically address
Sargon being in the front row and called
him a bunch of names and stuff which I
don't know you know I don't think that
was right to do I would have never done
that just play it cool man essentially
alright but she did that she's like and
this [ __ ] right here and [ __ ] that
guy I'm like whoa why I think the high
road for who are you teaching a moment
to there so do you know a conversation
she's like what is your audience like I
bet it's a bunch of a bunch of gamers
it's a bunch of those conservative
gamers I'm like well consider very
honest with you I did a poll right after
the election and about 20-some percent
of my audience could or did not vote
and about 30-some percent of audience
voted for Hillary hmm and about 30
percent of my audience voted for drama
and she's like doesn't that [ __ ]
disgust you and I'm like it's pretty
much right it's almost thirty thirty
what it yeah that's a that's a Democrat
but that's just a sample of the
population I'm like that to me is a
tremendous triumph that means my message
can be heard by anybody and I'm like
this need us to that everyone that
watches you doesn't agree with
everything you say I'm like Anita when
you talk who listens people already
worried with you though quite right
yeah but when I talk who listens people
who may not agree with me right and so I
I lean moderately left just slightly to
the left right and and so somebody who's
far right hears me say something that's
moderate then they might move closer
towards moderate yeah and then Anita you
can pick them up from there and take
them all the way to the goalposts but
that's not for me to do because I don't
give a [ __ ] about your goal post that's
your goal post right I give a [ __ ] about
the logical sane middle and if I can
bring somebody back from either side and
I get it
if I pull somebody from your team back
towards Center that's bad I understand
that but I'm bringing back people
towards the logical thinking metal when
I talk about the stuff and I think
that's where we all need to be because
that's how our country works right
mm-hmm agreeing to disagree kindly and
sweetly and and and then battling into
the courts battling into the polls
that's fine so we're supposed to do it
not in the [ __ ] streets the way you
are doing it people are getting [ __ ]
killed in charlottesville what are you
[ __ ] doing what are you [ __ ] doing
yeah and I know that's yeah so I thought
my career was over after the last VidCon
I thought I was just done it's my the
people on the Left were [ __ ] mad at
me the people the riot were [ __ ] mad
it's like yeah well you know here's the
thing the people in the middle we're
like oh no he's right that's cool and
that's 90 percent of us yeah you don't
hear them this happened to me so many
times we're like people get mad at me
it's inevitable and Nazi dog Whistler
Eden apparently I'm a [ __ ] a neo-nazi
all right er yeah Israeli right well no
G Israeli Jews you can't there's nothing
more Nazi on the work in the world I
know don't you know yeah so you're like
a war trophy I come on right um well
no people want any rate that's a hold
everything but [ __ ] was I talking about
the thing is you you hear all the
clamoring and all the everyone who's so
pissed comes like gone to all their
communities into your feed right and
they all they're all there supporting
each other and up voting and liking and
you and you feel when you look at it
like oh my god everybody [ __ ] hates
me very stuff what's the real truth is
that it's just like all these [ __ ]
people that are just so riled up and
when they go away after a couple days
the other 90% or more that weren't
really right didn't really [ __ ] find
it to be that big of a deal at all then
they're the mass more yeah a mass
majority people robbed them 98 percent
watched 8 percent of the video like I
agree with this or I disagree like yeah
whatever that was entertaining yeah and
then they watch the next video yeah and
then they like go to these when you have
how many more like 4.5 million but I
only have like a couple hundred thousand
but those are people that know who you
are
yeah so 10 percent of that you know is
400,000 people yeah so at that level
400,000 people which is only 10 percent
who were really [ __ ] angry at you
seems like the whole world's angry at
you right but then when they disappear
you realize it's especially like people
on on on an empower like some of these
journalists I already got was like
thrown under the bus by a journalist
from The New Yorker recently because I
said something that I wasn't
particularly proud of on Twitter and and
when I went back to read the message it
sounded very very wrong but in context
with the other tweets that went with it
it was fine
but when they isolated that one thing I
loved that dog by the way he's such a
surrogate Sammy since I've been there
such a good boy but like when in that
one taken out of context and then put
into their contacts because they quote
retweeted and and they're only doing it
because like they get extra followers
from it they get like then people
investing like oh he's so right he's so
woke he so whatever and they have like
no interest in seeing my point of view
or seeing what it is I'm trying to say
perfect example the Roseanne Barr thing
I think you had a little trouble so I
don't want to bring that up but I said
that racism is the web where did it's an
incorrect way to worse and I said racism
has a place in its calm in comedy um
when I meant by that maybe racial trope
right that's what I mean I was not even
necessarily that I think the way Dave
Chapelle he talked about Rick the black
white supremacist sketch is one of the
most amazing sketches of my life and
it's so educational so so I open what do
you mean he's nothing but limit you and
I don't necessarily think Roseanne Barr
should be calling people plan of the
eight monkeys and [ __ ] that's fine
[ __ ] but what I am saying is there is
a way to approach that topic that is
useful that is interesting that is
knowledgeable and it shouldn't be a
taboo topic that you can never touch
well Roseanne Barr did was not funny
mm-hmm and I should know better
yeah but make it funny make it
interesting make it educational make me
learn from it and I love the topic of
race and when the the boondocks in it or
when Richard Pryor did it or any Murphy
did it or or Dave Chappelle and I know
these are all people of color so I'll
even go to say early Lisa Levin le her
her very very racist humor was
interesting sometimes because it was
always in favor of people of color hmm
and I feel like even a bigot who's
listening to that gets a positive
feeling I think it's like maybe she's
right maybe they ain't so bad right and
that has a place right and so I don't
know but I got a lot of trouble I like a
couple sponsors rattling cages and
they're like oh that's a bad statement I
don't like what you're saying there and
I'm like I get that I'm not defending
Roseanne and then I go okay all right
that's just you know sometimes I've
learned sometimes you just gotta [ __ ]
I'm talking for myself of course just
well I heard Howard Stern say this I
thought it was great
he's like just sit down and shut up
nobody needs your [ __ ] opinion all the
time right and that was the problem I
made I just I I saw something and I
rattled off a statement that I came I
did I later disagreed with because
whatever right because I [ __ ] I think
that I know what I'm talking about I get
the information and I just I'm like you
[ __ ] this
but it's like nobody [ __ ] asked for
your opinion dude just shut up and sit
down
and then but then you but then you go
back on your opinion you know you change
you can change your opinion but you
already said it I know that's the
problem that's all the matters and that
one time at work right educate but now
that you're educated that still follows
you write 20 yeah and then people are
like you make an apology and people like
you ladies worse it's even worse your
[ __ ] [ __ ] you piece of [ __ ] Louis
yes JW's well it wasn't that it was the
people who are mad originally it was
proof that you know fudge is not good
and I was just saying did you know
that's you know my initials are my
initials are my name is Steven Jason
Williams I'm the original SJW I was
putting that into practice
bucking high score screens that's
[ __ ] before people notice that I saw
they saw my III match but yeah that's
the thing like I don't know we always
get judged by like those one stupid
thing we've ever done the one stupid
thing we said and that's the case we're
all gonna be found pretty shitty right
that's and then people try to
overcompensate because we all know we've
made a stupid mistake right so we're
trying to be super whoa queer extra walk
I'm my name on Twitter is not buggy 2:19
it's boogie killed the Nazis two nine
eight eight why I don't understand that
[ __ ] is am i what I've learned and what
I'm trying to implement is just like to
be more thoughtful before I speak cuz
I've always had a problem where I just I
have to talk too quickly and I need to
[ __ ] just shut up I haven't and say
something like in a way that I can stand
behind it I don't take ambien but I do
have that you know personality so that
post-traumatic stress disorder and I do
D personalized or disassociate or
whatever you call and I'm not making
smart choices most of the time I do that
and so some of the worst things I've
ever said on Twitter some things that
got me the most trouble I own it still
still mine just tell me yeah even I was
on ambien I still did it I have to pay
the price free that said some of the
stupidest [ __ ] I've said are miss worded
or made of misinterpret all I said it
when I wasn't in the thinking frame of
mine well I like in the talks in a case
of what you said you said there's a
place for racism I know what you meant
obviously that is not worded well
there's not what I meant no it's not
yeah I'm not saying you should treat
black comedians worse than white
comedians that's not what I'm [ __ ]
saying people how are you getting that
from it I'm not saying that a white
comedian should make jokes about black
people and how disgust
that's not something I'm saying you
should ever [ __ ] do I'm not saying
the black people are discussing are
awful I'm saying that's what the
comedian would say Jesus Christ it's it
makes you neurotic it makes me [ __ ]
neurotic it really does and when you
took a week off of social media I was
like oh god it's gonna be so [ __ ]
nice it was it was it was great and I
still kind of kept it in a way I don't
check it as much good I haven't but I
need to I check I'm I'm off I've pretty
much off Twitter and Instagram for the
most part like I'm not like before I was
like I have to post every day right to
like stay to keep up right what I'm I'm
like off I try to post and not even look
at some of the responses I love my
audience responses and I try to but the
very first negative one I'm like am done
yeah that's what I don't even want the
first negative one right because
ignorance is bliss
I do something that the late great John
vane totalbiscuit had trouble with this
entire life is I seek the negative we
all do
there's like a forum that exists out
there that's just dedicated to making
fun of youtubers hey can you grab
shredder most [ __ ] up subreddits and I
like find the people who hate me and
I'll just read this [ __ ] there's one
there's one redditor I swear to God if
if I if I ever get shot in the head this
is the guy he's the guy oh god he sounds
like posting literally every day about
me to 1015 times a day it's insane it's
insane
that's and the [ __ ] he's saying is like
straight crazy Oh God alright we are
nearing two hours oh yay we zipped and
zapped through this so I want to close
up because the first time we didn't get
the chance to ask you this but this is
kind of a segment that's popped up since
the last time you were here a year ago
do you have any ghost stories or Perry
did the ghost story it's what I think
one of you yeah I talked about meeting
the ghost of my mom right it was so we
talking about it and we were like no
that segment didn't exist then no [ __ ]
now give me some good at this part
here's what I will tell you to the
people at home okay a little bit late
let me give you a second to think okay
those of you out there who've been
watching me fail I have
tread water and I have drowned and I've
sucked in more water than I spat out
it's been a shitty seven years on
YouTube I've done some stupid [ __ ] and I
got to tell you if someone is dumb is me
you can get their [ __ ] together if
someone is lazy and has [ __ ] up and
like with all the damage that I've got
carrying around all this baggage you if
I can get my [ __ ] together if you're
listening at home know that you can get
your [ __ ] together and and I probably
will not always be successful I am very
aware that I might not lose every pound
that I want to lose I might very well
die of a heart attack sometime next year
I don't [ __ ] know I don't know how
this story plays out here's what I do
know I'm having the time of my life I'm
studying with two of my favorite
creators in the world right now I got a
cute little puppy right here I'm gonna
go meet my fans tomorrow they're gonna
shake my hands I got to go to e3 got to
meet Kojima I got to meet some of the
best game developers in the world I got
to sat down with the folks at CD Projekt
RED who are making cyberpunk and and
when they did the intro for the demo
they said what's up ladies and gentlemen
III they did my YouTube it right like
I'm I'm living and if I I thought this
was gonna happen five years ago seven
years ago
ten years ago I never thought I would
dug my way out of this hole and found
some joy and maybe you won't experience
the same things I'm experiencing but
you'll experience some joy right so just
get your [ __ ] together
and and don't make the stupid mistakes I
made of just waiting to die or fighting
to die like I saw a Fight Club and I
just made the stupidest decisions I was
like No
am I really trying to hit rock bottom
I'm not I should really try like I made
this as I made that conscious decision
after seeing that movie in 97 or
whatever um just don't be that guy just
just in the right if I get my [ __ ]
together you can get your [ __ ] together
and you deserve it way more than I do so
they would god bless that's beautiful
come back in here look like there's a
new [ __ ] we should do this in a year
yeah and I'm glad we circled back yeah I
am too
this was awesome I when I said here last
year and I was talking big I said to
myself I'm gonna do it but I wondered
for well mm-hmm and I did you did
Multi nightly and I can't wait for next
year I want to see
even you're gonna be another [ __ ]
another hundred pounds now that's been
surgery and hopefully up and running and
I'll probably never be a skinny person
I'll never I'll never be as as tiny as
is shredder down or even is you I'm you
know if I died tomorrow if I if I if I
went to my hotel tonight and lay down
bed and didn't wake up it was a life
well-lived I'm very happy with that but
I'm looking forward to coming back next
year and talking about all the other
hookers I've banged or whatever well
we're all rooting for you thanks man I
appreciate it man in your support I'm
you know people don't know this but I
talked to Ethan right after the divorce
I talked to you I talked to so many
creators the YouTube community so many
people in and the other side of it the
the the fans and you guys carried me
through this I mean you know I heard
from you and dm's I heard from DeFranco
I heard from Hank green I heard from Jon
I heard from tulane Community College
and I don't even know who he is but if
you like magic content check him out he
was one of the closest friends I could
ask for and Wedge who's another creator
who's currently just got out of back
surgery go check out his GoFundMe he
needs her help but just like I couldn't
believe I felt when that month and a
half before I could tell anybody
mmm I felt so alone in that month I
spent separated mmm I felt so alone I
had my friends but it was tough because
I couldn't even really talk to them
about it yet mm-hmm but the day I made
that video and then you reached out and
Hank and DeFranco and Jack and just God
truth is we all know how [ __ ] it is so
I think we all support each other
especially like on a personal level yeah
well I think when I was depersonalized
when I was when I was was going through
that I can't remember things I said and
did you guys carried me through it the
audience the soliciting right now at
home you guys carry me through it and
think I would have been successful
without you I don't think I'd pulled
anything off without you guys so thank
you I can't wait to see you next year
buggy yay thank you everybody for
watching and check out his channel if
you have more obviously buggy yeah you
go see some real melodramatic show
dropping tomorrow I think you're gonna
be super sad but it felt really good to
get off the chest and if and when you
listen to the stories don't feel bad for
me that's not what I'm interested in
I'm interested in you realizing if I can
survive that you can survive anything so
god bless hey guys thanks again this was
a great this was this was so fun I just
want to give a shout out to everybody on
YouTube we hit 40,000 yeah crazy man
thankful that's so much that's just a
blast guys next week we have Chris
D'Elia coming on Friday at the usual
time right then that's right and though
I didn't hear you but maybe they did and
the week afterwards we've got Bo Burnham
I'm so jealous I thought it was gonna be
really great and I got it then I got and
shreddies trying to get out then I get
to go see his movie I think I'm dying
we're seeing a screener on before why is
it a 10:00 a.m. because I might set 10
ago mine 7 that night we're seeing it
before he comes on but I'm excited I'm
so excited I can't I can't it says that
the movie looks amazing it's getting
really good reviews and I I'm actually
such a bobo new band and you grab
shredder uh Dan I'm actually such a beau
fan it's actually a little creepy this
time sorry Bo oh alright let's wrap this
up before shredder dies oh alright guys
thank you all we'll see you next week
thank you for watching we love him here
thank you
I get blessed and I hope you've enjoyed
the experience experience I am truly
saving experience see you next time guys
thanks for watching
[Music]